bonjour et bienvenue pour ce les visages
des deux probablement très spécial
puisque j'accueille le café d'essence
tout entier parce qu'en effet les
sciences et en plus on a un
enregistrement spéciale organisée par
podcast science c'est en particulier
bayelsa
du coup je pense que chacun de vous
présenter petit à petit mais sept au
total peut commencer par pin
bonjour tout le monde moi c'est pline je
fais la vulgarisation sur youtube sur
les sciences de l'éducation
bonjour moi je suis rémi alias bruzy
corps et je suis microblogueurs chimiste
café des sciences
mouassa bertrand la chaîne youtube de
mer quand j'explique tant logistiques et
instaurer science et je ne sais pas
pourquoi mes yeux aveugles au moment de
l'enregistrement donc les réponses de
johan et pelli ti n'ont pas été
enregistrés et puis il ya aussi qui
interviendra plus tard mais qui n'a pas
été introduite du coup ça me permet de
les introduire maintenant qu anne marqué
et docteur en informatique est également
vive est de la chaîne docteur à péron et
où il parle notamment de l'histoire des
mathématiques notamment parmi ses
dernières vidéos on trouve des vidéos
qui parle des mathématiques de l'egypte
antique pelli ti et dessinatrice
scientifique comment elle a un blog qui
s'appelle le p tit point fr où vous
retrouver de nombreux dessins est
également allé auteur d'un bogey qui
s'appelle le matériel et méthodes et
notamment le deuxième tome de ce manga
est sorti récemment et notamment dans
ses mangas elle met en scène des
personnages qui interagissent dans un
laboratoire de recherche et enfin et léa
qui interviendra plus tard elle est
docteur en biologie tam en biologie
végétale est allé aussi l'une des
principales animatrices de du podcast
podcast science et enfin il reste une
dernière personne à présenter qui est
agatha et du coup je cède la parole à
agueda puisque cet enregistrement a bien
fonctionné et moi je suis agatha et j'ai
un blog illustré je fais de la radio
pour parler de comportement animal
suivez le monde
du coup alors d'habitude je demande à
chacun de raconter une histoire de vie
c'est un petit peu si on fait ça de
l'ordre
du coup j'ai changé un petit peu mais
question la france que ce serait qu'on
parle un petit peu de terrain à savoir
qu'est-ce qu'ils écoulent en
vulgarisation le coincer par la première
question legata total me croquer les
placerait dans le lot de buts d'armand
de la vulgarisation ou là c'est une
vaste question que ça le but de
l'égalisation tu veux dire moi ce que je
gagne parce que j'ai envie de
transmettre
pourquoi tu fais ça ok et bat une telle
est l'idée réel vers les calculs du
temps alors moi niveau mondial c'est ce
rêve de toucher le plus large public
possible
alors j'ai un petit peu de la chance
parce que moi je dis gaz de l'éthologie
donc ça parle d'animaux ce qui est pas
forcément des concepts très abstrait ou
très difficile à se représenter donc
c'est un sujet entre guillemets sexy et
pas trop difficile à briser
ouais mon but est vraiment intéressé
même des gens qui n'aiment pas
particulièrement les sciences à
s'intéresser à ça comme ça fonctionne
hommes qu'ils apprennent des choses va
donner du plaisir aux gens
soyons un petit peu bisounours genre et
se serait cru que tout le monde à
prendre après mais c'est surtout ça je
pense que ça serait sympa mais si ça te
va ça va
donc moi mon but dans la vulgarisation
d'il ya deux aspects déjà moi je
vulgarise des pains vulgarise non
seulement la biologique mais je vous
dirais aussi la science comment elle
s'est fait et donc du coup c'est que
bain de la premier le premier côté c'est
voilà j'aimerais bien que des gens
croient qu'on puisse nous comprendre de
façon simple les concepts de la biologie
genre qu'est ce que c'est que les
coutrillons quand ça marche à des années
tout ça c'est ce que je fais à travers
mon blog et puis sinon
mon autre que qui est venir c'est assez
majeur du coup avec le mauvais que
j'écris cette aide matérielle méthode
c'est de vulgariser la recherche
scientifique c'est à dire de montrer aux
gens comment est ce qu'on fait de la
science au jour le jour et comment ce
combat comme ans qu'on travaille dedans
quels sont les problèmes qui se posent
au quotidien a été un super arrêt
qu'elle n'était pas si timide
ce que j'espère suivez redoublement de
28 kg c'est moi je parle de
mathématiques au début ce qui m'avait
motivé pour la vulgarisation c'est j'ai
toujours et un attrait pour la pédagogie
je me suis aperçu que les élèves en fait
du mal à comprendre les concepts de
maths déjà votre c'était abstrait mais
aussi parce que souvent le principal
truc c'est que ils ont des lacunes qui
s'accumulent au fur et à mesure et donc
pour moi ce qu'il fallait faire c'était
être capable de pouvoir présenter les
concepts du plus simple au plus
compliqué et pas comme s'il tombait du
ciel mais en aidant à comprendre comment
ils ont été formés comme les particules
pourquoi on n'est pas dans cette
direction là et j'ai fini par me dire
qu'en fait il fallait une approche
historique raconté les concepts dans
l'ordre où ils ont été inventés du coup
aussi raconté un petit peu la vie des
gens qui les ont produits dans quelle
société etc
et c'est pour ça du coup que j'ai
commencé par la mathématique grec pour
le coup mon approche et les pas très
différente de la tienne
mais pourquoi l'amélioration pour moi il
ya deux raisons une raison bien égoïste
comme il faut et une raison plutôt alto
liste donc la raison et voyez si c'est
plutôt d'approfondir mes connaissances
parce que le sujet qui me passionne mais
mais je les connais quand surface au
final du coup la chaîne youtube ça me
permet d'approfondir tous les sujets qui
engagent m'intéressait mais
vous voyez qu'en partie et puis la
raison altruiste bas c'est justement va
faire découvrir ces sujets que des gens
qui me connaissent je pense que tout le
monde connaît les sujets que j'aborde à
chaque fois c'est des sujets communs il
n'ya pas des sujets de niche mais que
ces gens là qui les connaissait
vaguement eux aussi face comme moi le
même cheminement se retrouve à être pas
non plus des experts mais un bien
méconnaître les sujets qui était
lointain pour eux avant de me connaître
la langue connaître bien d'autres
chaînes qui font la même chose
bien sûr je mets partout en fait d quand
quelqu'un me dit comment apprendre
électrique les ttc de l'expliquer fi
sync chaîne youtube blogs podcasts des
vrais notamment le podcast savoir entre
a très bien juste par connexion un peu
de 4 en ce moment elle était vraiment
très bien pour essayer de mettre ces
idées d exprimer
donc pour ma part le domaine c'est la
chimie nice pas forcément le 2 mai le
plus sexy à pouvoir développer en public
d'une part parce que ces objets font
parfois peur produits chimiques etc
pollution c'est des domaines assez de
chez parfois société donc on va dire il
ya un double objectif à la fois c'est
vers le public essayez un peu plus
d'énergie et craindre la chimie et aux
cycles et en soule est un peu manipulée
à s'intéresser à cette chose mais aussi
une double casquette plus orienté vers
les professionnels de la médiation
puisque je suis aussi un volet relecteur
c'est-à-dire un dans le monde donc aussi
permettre aussi à des gari thater qui
voudraient se lancer dans la cheminée
parfois aussi cette l'appréhension
comptes publics et plus le côté pratique
de la chose aussi de les motiver qu'ils
peuvent aussi parlé de chemy qu'ils
auront du mal à réguler dupontel de qui
comme lui a atteint alors par exemple
j'ai aidé par exemple docteur dodman
pour faire certaines gilles dr qui
docteur ousmane qui a fait par exemple
pour qu'ils aient des acides assez
puissant qui nécessite des précautions
vous avancez que la normale j'ai aussi
aidé expérimente boyle est ce que ces
futurs eux et aussi la re lecture de
scripts + sport à nice par exemple
arnaud chasseneuil et d'autres membres
du café des sciences dont les premiers
servis du coup elle dans une soie
sessegnon parti à l'intérieur d'un
appartement tugar that her name on
escompte très limité on a souvent besoin
de dix coups des jo parce que tu paies
du coup c'était quoi la question quel
est le but de tabulation ou est ce que
tu veux en venir
ok to michael mon idéal c'est à la base
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
pulvérisation en gardant des chaînes
youtube ou de drogues surtout les
chaînes youtube je pense quand ça a
vraiment commencé et j'ai fait un master
en sciences de l'éducation et je me suis
rendu compte qu'il ya des riens qui se
faisait en tout cas j'ai rien trouvé
et même dans le milieu anglophone avec
très peu de trucs là dessus et du coup
ça m'a motivé à me lancer puisque moi
j'en aurais eu besoin jeune fille doit
peut-être que j'en avais besoin
et avec le temps ça s'est un petit peu
clarifiée je me suis rendu compte de
l'intérêt n'en que ça pouvait avoir
décidé de faire des biens entre la
recherche en éducation et le terrain
parce que principaux 20 mon public cible
idéalement ça va être surtout des
enseignants des parents des éducateurs
des formateurs trices et du coup le fait
de faire ce lien entre la recherche et
leurs pratiques
ça peut leur donner des gi qui vont les
aider dans leurs pratiques et du coup en
bout de ligne ça peut aller toucher
vraiment beaucoup de personnes puisqu'il
ya beaucoup de l'enseignant et donc
beaucoup d'enfants encore plus derrière
qui peuvent en bénéficier si les
pratiques éducatives en général peuvent
s'améliorer
voilà je pense que mon but c'est autant
que possible de créer des communautés
qui
il participe à construire ce lien entre
la recherche et l'éducation
ce que vous pensez qu'il ya suffisamment
de terrorisation et quels sont ceux que
penser que devrait y avoir plus de gens
confondent à pulvérisation que les
scientifiques vulgariser que d'un
scientifique les vrais pollueurs ise
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'un manque
de vulgarisation encore l'heure qu'il
est cette impression parce que c'est moi
qui revient ce qui leur est propre aux
couleurs
c'est une très bonne question
au niveau de sp scientifique devoir
faire plus de vulgarisation moi je le
pense le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans la recherche publique blindes point
de vue très différents après ça dépend
des milieux moi je sais que le milieu
dont je suis issue les gens de mon
laboratoire était très frileux à l'idée
de faire la légalisation pour plein de
raisons
ce qu'il n'avait pas de temps parce que
la roche la vulgarisation ce n'est pas
valorisé auprès des cahiers des charges
générées c'est donc beaucoup estiment
que c'est de la perte de temps et
d'énergie
mais aujourd'hui en france on l'a vu il
ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont plus
confiance dans la science fixe dans la
science et oubliez que les scientifiques
sont des citoyens comme les autres que
la recherche joly qui est fait avec les
impôts des citoyens
moi j'estime que les gens ont droit de
savoir ce qu'on fait nos labos et que
souvent ça m intéresse c'est juste que
est ce que les scientifiques sont les
plus adaptés à le faire c'est pas sûr
parce qu'on peut être un excellent
chercheur et un très bon pédagogue dans
ce cas peut-être que des vulgarisateurs
ou en tout cas des gens qui sont
peut-être entre les deux qui ont fait de
la recherche qui n'en font plus ou qui
sont un peu l'interface sont les bonnes
personnes justement faire la passerelle
entre les deux milieux
mais en tout cas oui moi je pense que
c'est essentiel que y ait cet échange
entre le grand public et la science
oui je suis complètement d'accord avec
toi je pense que le problème c'est
publie les académiques ne reconnaît pas
la valeur de la vulgarisation ou
peut-être quelques elle dit qu'elle le
fait mais pour ce qui est des
recrutements des financements ou de tout
ce qui va être la matérialité de la
recherche
ça va ça va jamais être récompensé c'est
même plutôt un handicap puisque tu as
pas un profil très classique et ça tu
vas observée lors des 26 ans qui ont
fait la fédération et qui ont été moins
bien à très calmes on sait que c'est
quelque chose
bah moi quand j'avais essayé de faire
pas mal de recrutement j'avais essayé de
demander aux laboratoires ce qu'ils ont
pensé et c'est bien ils étaient
indifférents ou bien miser mais t'as pas
un profil classique donc du coup ça va
pas être important pour nous voir tu vas
être suspicieux eux mêmes donc c'est
vraiment pas à valoriser
je connais le carl sagan effect non si
je fais quelques uns des autres koné qui
veut expliqué me baboucar sagan qui est
un très grand réalisateur inquiété dans
les idées justement que je suis tombé
dans le piège car c'est elle qui est un
très grand physicien qui a fait des
recherches très bonne qualité
il s'est fait vu refuser la senior dans
une grande diversité
et puis après il n'a pas été non plus
admis à l'académie des sciences
désolé j'espère que quelqu'un en savez
plus que moi mais est apparemment dans
fait en termes de publications les
cliques et au dessus de gens qui était
accepté
on ignore ou à la cave et des méfiances
et apparemment ça serait parce que les
gens une mauvaise vision devait pas ce
qu'est ce que c'était aussi très très
accessible oui et même un mépris parce
que c'est vu les révélateurs tu vas dire
des choses qui ne sont pas exacts on
parlait juste au grand public qui qui
sont pas assez sérieuse temps passé par
les pairs où il assimile pas que c'est
une forme différente de communication
fait pas beaucoup moi je réponds juste
par mon bout de la lorgnette nom
scientifique
donc j'espère veut pas peur de leurs
sujets alors bien sûr il faut pas dire
qu'ils passaient du gard isation sinon
personne ne se traînant dans le jeu même
si je n'aime pas trop ça fait ça le jeu
ou km forcément faut pas dire qu'il est
là c'est parce qu'il faut qu'il joue
plus en plus de gens qui tentent leur
chance coty qui attise la curiosité et
du coup attise la curiosité du public
donc voilà on y est bien sûr il n'y en a
pas assez
et d'ailleurs heureusement que je ne
suis pas dit ça va même si à la base ma
chaîne s'était pas de la science pure et
dure
qu'est ce qu'un client saga l'année 2010
est à l'époque qui avait commencé de la
physique
il y avait les guides science étonnante
qui était encore une vidéo toutes les
trois semaines
ils pensaient qu'ils qui était il y
avait encore de grosses productivité
donc si je m'étais dit non c'est bon il
ya c'est du gladiateur mais je ne serais
pas lancée aujourd'hui moment et surtout
ne pas se dire que tous les sujets ont
été traités
i en effet ils ont été tous traités
peut-être mais il ya toujours l'angle
qui compte puis standard de traiter à
nouveau voilà tout à fait mais
l'apprentissage c'est l'art et l'art de
la répétition
c'est important de répéter que si on y
ajoute un peu de manière un peu
différente c'est vrai et ça qui a pas
mal de sujets que je pars d'un projet de
gouvernement des livres que j'ai pas
forcément compris reproche à la première
fois que je vois après ensuite traitées
en vidéo et je les comprends parce que
ils ont peut-être été différent pas
forcément que c'était mieux expliqué m
différents ça me david alexis bien tu
peux dire un bon coup là je passais je
ne sais plus patience voilà j'avais
c'est lui qui m'a fait comprendre
s'allume alors qu'higuain réputé
compréhensible je suis plus mitigé mais
non le problème principal de feynman
après si tu as lu ses livres ses feynman
c'est un formidable vulgarisateur mais
quand même pour physiciens un petit peu
avertis mais ce soit c est pas alors il
a fait des conférences mme anthony qui
seront les niayes mais par contre si tu
veux vraiment repris les cours de
feynman la physique et la saine des
révélations parfaitement jeu après la
question qui donc là on est abordée
plein de sujets sur l île à ces deux
organisations
alors d'une part au niveau
institutionnel on a quand même un peu
modéré qu'on commence timidement à voir
des offres notamment les doctorants sont
plus en plus encouragés à
familiarisation agatha qui a été
doctorante l'est un peu plus mais moi je
suis sur paris saclay donc comme on a un
organisme de médiation scientifique la
miss donc du coup ils sont très en
demande à voir des doctorants pour
pouvoir animer des ateliers pour se
trouve que moi je suis technicien
danalyse donc je ne rentre pas dans ces
clowns donc moi munitions de gars
isation sont pas du tout m'encourager
donc c'est sur mon temps libre
faut voir aussi que le milieu de la
bulgarie assure actuellement il est
assez précaire donc plein de thunes
tu penses que c'est comment dire que
c'est pas forcément encourager en effet
pour avoir des sapeurs
c'est après ce qu elle suffisamment de
médiation scientifique bon je suis dans
un prendre et ce peut-être avec le
prisme de nos disciplines je crois que
chaque personne qui sait comment ces a
fallu la médiation scientifique c'était
parce qu'en péter vers un manque donc
finalement entre finalement qui est
toujours un manque de dents prêts je
suis pas vidéaste et souvent sur le
devant de la scène où le me permettrais
pas de dire qu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
de médiation mais oui pas de dire mais
quand même normal dira mais il ya
effectivement toujours à un fossé a
toujours de la place pour des gens pour
apporter leurs connaissances et s'est
fortement encouragé le sein de la
communauté
je dirais que il ya peut-être pas je
sais pas si ça fait du sens en fait de
parler de la vulgarisation en général
parce que tel que ce qu'on vient
chercher
par exemple moi je vais m'intéresser
j'ai pas dis quoi la bio et à l'histoire
du coup je vais aller suivre des blogs
ou des chaînes des podcasts parle de bio
d'histoire mais ça veut pas dire que
voilà si quelqu'un a des goûts très
spécifiques
il va peut-être pas trouvé comment au
début j'ai pas trouvé le truc sur les
sciences de l'éducation de
l'apprentissage
eh ben est ce qu'il ya un public pour
tous les sujets les plus absurdes et est
ce que il ya des gens qui sont prêts à
s'attaquer à des sujets qui touchent
peut-être une plus petite communauté où
est ce que le but justement de la
vulgarisation c'est d'aller sur des
trucs un peu sexy qui vont toucher un
très large public comme on l'a donc
est-ce qu'il ya assez de vulgarisateur
je pense que ça dépend vraiment de ce
qu'on attend de la vulgarisation est ce
que c'est en général de la vulgarisation
parce qu'aujourd'hui commence à y avoir
une grosse grosse diversité de sujets
mais il ya aussi un décalage énorme
entre certaines disciplines certains
thèmes qui sont beaucoup plus traités
que d'autres vins typiquement les trucs
autour de l'histoire ou deux
la biologie par exemple vont être
beaucoup plus traiter que certaines
sciences humaines la philosophie aussi
pas mal traitée mais des trucs comme la
sociologie en a encore assez peu s'il y
en a les mathématiques sont aussi assez
bien représenté je pense mais il ya
d'autres disciplines qui vont être
beaucoup moins comme l'éthologie
peut-être un gagnant donc voilà selon
quelles sont les attentes aussi des
publics qu'est-ce que le but est
justement de demander à chacun de faire
un petit peu de vulgarisation et du coup
la proportion va refléter peut-être la
proportion qu'on retrouve dans la
recherche est typiquement s'il ya
beaucoup moins de recherche qui sont
financés en philosophie on s'attendrait
à voir beaucoup moins deux vidéos de
philosophie par rapport à des vidéos
physique donc je ne sais pas et ensuite
où est le public est ce que parce qu' on
a des publics qui vont s'intéresser à
plein de sujets différents parce que en
général c'est affublé risation est par
exemple c'est juste de youtube on est
attiré d'une chaîne vers une heure
d'hiver une autre vers une autre
finalement c'est plus la plateforme
youtube qui va nous garder captifs à
regarder la vulgarisation quelqu'un peu
importe la discipline c'est plus la
forme qui compte mais ce que c'est
vraiment le fond des sujets précis parce
qu'on a envie d'apprendre des trucs dans
un domaine particulier
mais ça je ne serai pas dire ça dépend
des gens je pense que tu ya beaucoup de
diversité à ce qu'on voit là d'autant
aussi que certaines questions que je
vais que je pose à moi je voudrais
inviter aussi qu'il ya une certaine
diversité des médias qu'on utilise pour
le bugue à vrai dire il ya pas mal de
sasebo tradis pas mal en vidéo par
exemple mais voilà il ya notre caste il
ya la bd le blog même si enfin voilà on
est pas tous attirés vers les mêmes
formes de médias je pense du coup c'est
aussi important qu'on garde sa diversité
et je pense que du coup bah voilà il ya
la diversité des domaines à traiter mais
aussi la diversité des médias à couvrir
c'est à dire que moi par exemple je
regarde pas des masses de vidéos donc du
coup je suis plutôt contente que tu
regardes
je regarde et y est inquiète et du coup
voilà c'est pour ça que j marc c'est
aussi bien je suis content d'eux va
pouvoir lire je peins mois des billets
de sciences en bd par exemple ce genre
de choses et du coup way où il ya eu
aussi la vulgarisation qu'on fait en
revanche pas voir en atelier ou au musée
qui est pas du tout la même forme en
fait et on n'est pas tous sensibles à la
même chose donc du coup je pense que
c'est aussi bien qu'on soit nombreux
pour pouvoir couvrir à la fois
université de sujets à la fois
universités médias est-ce que je pense
que les saisons et des médias qui sont
en ce moment un peu sous couvert et
qu'il faudrait d'acheteurs
particulièrement ce méga ouais parce que
je sais pas je dirais qu'il ya des
milieux qui sont ouverts un peu en
désuétude
je veux dire le blog par exemple blog
c'était hyper populaire à une époque est
en fête bat maintenant on passe plus
d'heures du micro blogging a du coup va
sur les réseaux sociaux est en fait le
blog c'est quand même une forme qui est
assez différente on peut s'étendre sur
des bibles beaucoup plus long beaucoup
plus détaillée avec des références et
c'est donc vraiment c'est pas et puis ça
se perd moins aussi facilement dans le
temps donc c'est plus facile à retrouver
par exemple
donc ouais je trouve que le blog un peu
tombé en désuétude et bah oui comme on
parlait avec la bd évidemment la bd
alors la bd publiées je trouve qu'il ya
vachement que ceux des bd scientifiques
en ce moment et donc ça c'est plutôt
raide mais sans nous dire voilà il ya
enfin des bd scientifique qui arrive
dans les rayons des librairies
ce que quelque chose d'obscur et c'est
plus quelque chose comme on garde aussi
dans nos blogs personnels et tout donc
voilà ça c'est quelque chose si tu aime
bien recevoir développer ce qe2 des
remarques voir d'autres gens qui pensent
que les médias type de rennes tous
couverts
c'est peut-être pour revenir elle
complété là dessus si je prends le média
youtube que celui que je connais le
mieux
on peut regarder les tranches d'âge
aussi de sa touche et du coup c'est vrai
que ça reste une tranche d'âge et 11 16
35 ans pour l'immense majorité de ceux
qui font de la ville via scientifique
donc on peut se demander si d'autres
médias vont aller toucher d'autres
personnes
typiquement est-ce que d un public plus
âgé serait intéressé par d'autres formes
de vulgarisation peut-être plus des
livres des bd ça je sais pas si les bd
mais qu'est ce que le même public dans
des tranches d'âge je sais pas ce que tu
en penses
après parce qu'on parle de bd alors je
fais un très court a porté sur la bd
mais la bd c'est comme le roman c'est à
dire qu'il ya quantité de gens
république ultra large en bd
scientifique on s'est toujours marion
montaigne avec tu mourras moins bête qui
était un blog qui a été dit et ensuite
un banc disney et honnêtement marée
monte enfin je pense qu'elle a touché
tous les publics c'est à dire même là la
fée nabédé d'un complice thomas pesquet
qui a explosé tous les records de vente
je pense qu'il ya aussi bien des enfants
de 8 ans passionnée par les voyages dans
l'espace que des grands-parents de 70
ans qui l'ont lu parce que c'était le
top ventes de noël je pense que tout le
monde se dit offert à côté ça il ya des
trucs beaucoup plus spécifique par
exemple il ya une collection qui était
assez chouette chez le lombard qui
s'appelle la petite de l'été que des
savoirs ou c'était un duo un chercheur 1
est un dessinateur donc le contenu était
toujours très poussée vérifiez etc
mais où s'étaient alors ça dépend de des
numéros il ya des numéros y ait beaucoup
plus de textes que d'autres mais où je
pense que c'était déjà un public
intéressé en la vie je peux me tromper
mais je pense que le public ado jeunes
adultes et est moins ciblée que par
exemple marmontel janvier donc au niveau
des tranches d'âge c'est peut-être
beaucoup plus difficile de prévoir qui
va les lire je dirais globalement jeunes
adultes
c'est large et pas très précis après
j'arrive à faire le format de bd il
assez comme cet avantage d'être très
ouvert c'est à dire que y'a là foyers
des personnes de très jeunes qui m'ont y
avait des personnes très âgées et je
pense ça dépend aussi pas mal du style
de l'auteur et de sa popularité
du coup il ya voilà la petite bédéthèque
des savoirs c'est vraiment un public
plutôt adulte qui est visée clairement
alors que je pense qu'il ya aussi de la
bd jeunesse qui peut se développer
autour de ça il peut intéresser plus
ouais ouais c'est difficile à dire en
finale j'ai l'impression que un petit
monde le dit mais justement je le
conseille à partir de dijon 2-3
après pour rebondir sur l'aspect médias
l'a finalement ce qu'on associés médias
finalement avec un support parce que bon
ma principale activité de hull grise à
sion je suis pas en dehors c'est sur
twitter dont il ya réseaux sociaux qui
peuvent qui la plupart du temps et juste
un outil promotionnel pour pouvoir
discuter avec des personnes y sont moins
potentiel parce que c'est là où les gens
vont et donc finalement pour aller
chercher ces gens et les amener vers des
questions
les réseaux sociaux sont des choses
intéressantes après avoir par exemple
faudrait que je regarde et apparemment
il ya aussi d'aider médiatique de faire
la médiation sur instagram toujours
vives toujours 6ème soir photo soit
vidéo je sais pas s'il ya des médias
comme des médias récent genre tik tok
pourrait se formaliser afin de la
médiation scientifique allaient encore
chercher de public mais ça finalement il
ya autant de supports qu'il ya des
endroits où les gens se rencontrent et
sont susceptibles d'échanger avec
quelqu'un
donc ouais ok c'est bon de savoir qui
sont les amis un support n'a pas encore
mentionné
et en plus ce qu'on a la chance d'avoir
des gros médias géorgiens aux joies ses
officiers la coordinatrice de paille top
5 en france et d alors c'est tout neuf
parce que je vais aider le dit chabrol
qui est près du festival cette année à
organiser la coordination nationale
effectivement c'est un aspect de la
vulgarisation qui est important c'est
d'aller sur le terrain à est d'aller le
rencontrer les gens pour de vrai pour
ceux qui connaissent pas et hop ça y est
le principe c'est de faire venir des
chercheurs dans les bars pour qu'ils
discutent de leurs sujets de recherche
s'assurent vulgariser et qu'il explique
au au public voilà je vis c'était quoi
la question
est ce que tu penses qu'ils pensent
manque encore de d'efforts comme ça de
référence et pines ces liens se
répondent pour moi un besoin qui
peut-être moins évident à riz par
exemple dans des grandes villes il ya
déjà plein d'initiatives dans les
régions quand c'est pas paris souffre il
ya des initiatives pour les scolaires
dans les écoles
ensuite il ya des initiatives aux
horaires ou les gens organisent dans les
institutions donc entre 8 heures et midi
et entre 14 et 17 heures donc
typiquement qui peut venir à ce genre de
truc en semaine c'est les retraités et
les gens qui travaillent pas et des
choses le soir ou le reste des gens donc
les jeunes actifs peuvent aller y avait
pas beaucoup et donc pines haynes ba1
répondre à ce besoin et en plus on va
dans des bars donc c'est le lieu où les
gens groupe après le travail pour pour
discuter soit trouvée et ça c'est des
initiatives importantes et je pense que
ça va se continuer à parfaire sa yam
peut-être que je peux parler un peu de
mon expérience je suis pas rentré dans
la vulgarisation du tout par youtube ou
par les réseaux sociaux je suis rentré
par l'animation donc à la taille que
j'étais aux petits débrouillards donc
j'allais dans les quartiers à strasbourg
pour faire des animations concrète avec
avec les enfants et j'ai toujours été
dans l'animation avant de découvrir
qu'il y avait des gens qui de garissa
sûr sur youtube et riche voilà je pense
que youtube tout seul ne peut pas
répondre à la demande de tout bon il ya
des publics qui sont pas sur internet
simplement et donc c'est important de
regarder des trucs pour la vraie vie
aussi
je suis à ce que ce dossier on pense à
d'autres médias où je m'explique mois
juste pour revenir là dessus on en
revient toujours un petit peu au nerf de
la guerre
la thune super cher en fait ce serait
génial en fait si on pouvait plus
intervenir directement auprès des
changes en vrai parce que l'on va pas se
mentir par écran interposé bassin d
humanisme on perd quelque chose de super
important pour la science justement par
certains entre cap est vu comme un peu
froide très distantes de notre quotidien
et un début de la vulgarisation selon
moi c'est justement gré et humaniser ça
entre ça fun est intéressant est de
faire en sorte que tout le monde se
sente concerné il peut importe de calais
six ans on parle là pour le coup c'est
vraiment plus comprendre qu'est-ce que
c'est faire donation c'est qu'il ya une
diversité justement de méthodes de
pratique mais ce côté humain justement
il est essentiel mais la grosse
difficulté pour mettre ça en place à
large échelle
c'est que ça prend des gens qui doivent
être payés parce que ça va travailler
quoi c'est souvent une heure un problème
qui revient sur le financement des gens
qui s'investissent comme ça sur des
initiatives comme ça le fait et des
bénévoles partout qu organise des petits
trucs ça légitime le fait que la
communication scientifique ne soit pas
professionnel jamais ce qui est un
problème en soi c'est un peu un cercle
vicieux est ce que on demande aux gens
de s'investir d'un événement pour que
les choses existent parce que s'ils sont
pas là il n'y a rien ou est-ce qu'on
arrête tout pour que les gens se disent
ah ya un manque il faudrait qu'on fasse
quelque chose d'artificiel
c'est toujours un peu le problème est
bon en attendant d'avoir quelque chose
de gros et des normes qui fonctionnent
avec des gros financements etc
c'est quand même pas mal qui est plein
de petites initiatives pour boucher les
trous
en attendant de lemieux quoi oui il faut
il faudrait mieux à ce sujet là il ya
une communauté un peu similaire à la
nôtre c'est celle qui a donné
aujourd'hui les intermittents du
spectacle qui ont traversé plusieurs
phases de financement de leur communauté
au début c'était ils réduisaient le
l'accès à leur communauté il fallait
avoir une carte qui disait par exemple
tu fais un musicien professionnel tu es
aimé du coup ça se tait réaliser l'accès
aux amateurs dans un deuxième temps
après la guerre ça a été plutôt un
financement étatique par le système de
subventions etc s est récemment que
maintenant il ya la cotisation
interprofessionnelle pour financer le
statut d'intermittent du spectacle en
sachant que les trois phases avec des
avantages et des inconvénients et encore
aujourd'hui en train de se chercher nous
sur quel modèle on pourrait bien adopter
pour financer
communauté excité en fait juste ici
est-ce qui a déjà levé demain donc ce
sera très visuel sur le podcast mais qui
a déjà fait une intervention bdbuzz papa
de jean et qui a déjà fait une intention
rémunéré ici un petit beurre c'est
certain ça dans sa bulle pour préciser
leurs et venir et c'est pas différent du
défraiement
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont
défrayé jargon rend plus parce que faut
pouvoir se déplacer finalement le
déplacement cher et aussi le rémunérer
c'est vraiment dans des cas très
spécifiques et ça demande un budget
conséquent que malheureusement beaucoup
comme tu l'as dit le milieu et surtout
associatif et on comprend aussi que les
associations n'ont pas forcément les 100
ml pour nous faire venir un autre
problème c'est le statut de
fonctionnaire c'est à dire que s'il ya
des chercheurs qui veulent enfin même
pas fonctionnaire mais être en contrat
avec un organisme public le cnrs
l'enseignement supérieur à voir et c'est
ça envie d'être payés uniquement par
cette institution est de ne pas être
payé par quoi que ce soit d'autre à côté
à moins d'avoir des dérogations
spécifiques validé par les ressources
humaines etc
donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
envie de s'investir dans la
vulgarisation mais qui reste sur du
bénévolat juste parce que légalement bas
on n'aurait pas le droit de gagner 2-1
parle aussi de l'expérience
d'intervention améliorée dans quel cadre
c'était trop de politesse ici c'est mon
silence alors vraiment au niveau de mes
interventions rémunérés en fait ce qui
se passe c'est qu'après ma thèse du coup
je suis devenue indépendante
donc j'ai un statut de micro entreprises
et d'arrivée bethke
j'ai eu deux interventions j'ai une
médiathèque qui m'a contacté qui voulait
une conférence très spécifique sur
homme-animal c'était dans le cadre du
festival
la science se livre en février à
gennevilliers et donc la médiathèque
j'en avais un devis et ils m'ont payé
pour une conférence précise et un autre
job que j'ai eu c'est le musée rue de
lille qui m'a contacté et m'a dit là on
aura besoin de deux bras en plus pour
monter une exposition et donc ça s'est
fait comme ça
dans un cas de figure pour jeunes vis
des ses rangs moi qui fais mondeville
pour le muséum c'était plus en fonction
de leur enveloppe dans sa housse vois ça
ne vois pas où trouver
voilà ouais ouais enfin c est trop de
l'ordre de grandeur après au niveau des
rémunérations c'est ce que en discuter
entre nous pendant la retraite c'est
très très très variable moi ça m'est
déjà arrivé de faire des interventions
où j'étais que d'effrayer donc là je
t'ai pas rémunéré on va juste le biais
tra et d'hébergement si besoin
j'ai déjà fait des conférences ou c'est
200euros parce que c'est une conférence
où j'avais déjà fait bénévolement par
ailleurs et donc ça ne devrait pas
énormément de travail de le refaire pour
gennevilliers
je veux le dire en tout n'était vu que
c'était une conférence nouvelle d'une
heure qui m'a demandé par les bio du
travail
c'était 900 pour parce que ça demande
une semaine de boulot donc si on met au
taux horaire finalement c'est pas si
cher payé et et ça va beaucoup aux vins
c'est très très variable quand on peut
se demander après il ya aussi par
exemple la charte des auteurs qui existe
qui peut donner des indications c'est
très compliqué de facturer son travail
où je suis intervenu par exemple dans
une classe de maternelle pendant deux
heures je devais créer un deux jeux et
faire 2 min contre 2,15 minutes parce
que tu es enfant tu si l'on veut pas
faire des combos d'une heure d'une
traité pour possible et ça par exemple
j'ai pas eu le choix en fait la somme a
dit là le tarif de la charte de l'auteur
deux heures de temps alors ça prend pas
en compte la préparation deux heures de
temps en présentiel 7 200 euros
et voilà d'accord ça prend pas en compte
le temps présent qu il faut soit
rentabilisée vachement son temps de
travail se dire ok je fais et que 200
donc j'y consacre tintin mais en général
quand c'est quelque chose c'est pour ça
que moi je concert on n'a pas abordé
mais je trouve ça plus facile de
vulgariser un sujet qu'on connaît déjà
ce que ça me manque de moins de l'aude
du bio haut que moi en éthologie des
fois il ya des choses qui peuvent être
très très éloignées mené sujet de
recherche donc ça demande aussi du
boulot et c'est vrai que vaille à ce
compromis de je veux bien faire je veux
pas dire de bêtises je veux vérifier mes
sources et le fait que défendre ne pas
payer beaucoup faire ce travail de
préparation et je parle de ton
expérience vraiment mon expérience à un
peu similaire aussi j'ai pas fait
beaucoup d'interventions
j'ai fait une table ronde à la fac
belliot et là c'est pareil j'ai été
rémunérée sur la grille la charte des
auteurs enfin tout simplement ont
l'avantagé table ronde c'est ça donne
pas beaucoup de préparation donc là pour
le coup je trouvais que c'était plutôt
plutôt bien d'après the race du temps
souvent enfin avec les propositions que
j'ai c'est on attend de budget qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec ce budget et les
adjoints globalement fait c'est prendre
le problème d'absence
bah voilà en fait voilà on n'a pas plus
on est une petite asso on est elle cette
petite structure et ben voilà qu'est ce
que tu peux nous proposer pour cette
somme là et après bah c'est à nous de
voir ce qu'on peut faire
sachant que ben voilà c'est un certain
difficile en fait d'estimer à l'avance
le temps qu'on va y passer
sachant qu'on a toujours envie de faire
bien et nous pouvons pas forcément il
est passé de résistant que prévu et donc
voila moi c'est tout cas l expérience
que j'en ai jusqu'à maintenant c'est
plutôt ce genre de jeu remich
leur moi ce sont des informations
encadreuse colère donc c'était via une
association qui est 93 est allé chercher
un financement pour pouvoir développer
un projet pédagogique les artificiel
donc le but c'était que durant quarante
heures et un chimiste qui présente la
science est un artificier qui présente
son métier d'artificier pour le but
qu'ils puissent à la fin tirer leurs
propres feux d'artifice donc ils vont
faire le blanc la musique etc
pendant deux séances moi j'aurais fait
des démonstrations de chimie pour pour
expliquer tous bien à la couleur du feu
d'artifice
comment elle fonctionne une fusée pour
que ça explose correctement et c'est
donc ça fait des projets qui demandent
de l'argent puisque tiré un feu
d'artifice coûte cher la chimie c'est
qu'ils énormément de consommables donc
c'est encore plus cher donc pour cette
intervention j'ai été donc pour ma part
c'était à cinq séances de faux voeux
cinq fois deux heures en collège et
j'étais les pays à 700 euros pour sa
part jeudi j'ai été payé je suis
fonctionnaire aussi donc je ne peux pas
prendre directement donc c'est via le
café des sciences qu'on a pu recevoir
l'argent donc c'est le café des sciences
qui lie à ses 700 euros j'ai pas été
payées directement 7 euros pour cent
cinq potes deux heures c'est ça
effectivement ça c'est parfait c'est
toujours le problème particulier de la
chimie c'est qu'elle est à dire on
utilise des consommables et donc ça fait
que j'accumule fur et à mesure de faire
des interventions du matériel dont il ya
aussi une partie matérielle que je
récupère au fur et à mesure que je ne
paye plus et j'ai du mal aussi à
quantifier cette partie fermée
breaking bad tutelle
et peut-être pour vérifier pour les gens
qui c'est vrai que en 1700 euros c'est
pas beaucoup
une dizaine d'heures de travail mais en
vrai faut vraiment se souvenir de tout
le travail qui est pas qu'ils aient pas
compter toutes les heures de travail en
allemand préparer tout ça grandit c'est
d'abord où c'est pas comme ancrage sur
70 euros de l'heure puisque en réalité
c'est pas du tout 60 il ya des dizaines
d'heures de préparation en amont et
c'est donc effectivement c'est quand
même des montants qui peuvent paraître
assez croquant se dit waouh plusieurs
centaines d'euros
quelques interventions ponctuelles c'est
génial allez en fait ça reste d'une part
très précaire parce que si c'est facturé
en tant que l'écran entreprise auto
entrepreneurs c'est pas de l'argent
nécessairement au courant on touche où
il ya des taxes qui vont être payés faut
aussi compter qu'on cotise pas du tout
pour la retraite ou pour des aides
sociales etc
quand tu vois la fin je pense remettre
dans le contexte un petit peu quand on
parle d'argent savoir est-ce que c'est
beaucoup est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup
comprendre combien il ya d'argent
vraiment dans notre poche au final et
combien d'heures de travail ça a demandé
aussi ça prend pas en compte tout le
temps qu'on a mis pour trouver parfois
les contrats sachant que souvent c'est
parce que en tout cas pour beaucoup de
vulgarisateur et vulgarisatrice que je
connais on a commencé en tant que
bénévole et s'est fait connaître petit à
petit mais tout ce temps là parfois des
centaines d'heures de travail compte pas
dans le dans la balance mais pourtant
c'est vraiment du temps on a investi qui
nous a aidés à nos professionnels
puisqu'il transports pierre précarité
pour 7 points à avoir un truc que c'est
pas tant que ça fait comme beaucoup de
travail pour finalement pas tendre pas
tant que ça mais tous pensent que c'est
intéressant parce que mon encore entre
qu'ils quitteraient les inconnus il m'a
dit retraite tous chez moi j'ai un
contrat comme ça c'est un peu inédit
quoi c'est un peu une nouvelle aventure
vous savez je pense que c'est important
qu'on se coordonne un petit peu sur sa
queue aussi les embauches heures
potentiel
et une idée de ce à quoi peuvent
s'attendre si on demande et les services
un gars de terre de café les sims 3
c'est renarde par rapport à ça sinon je
vais en revenir à la question de qui
avait soulevé des remarques à l'effet
primes sur les différents sujets ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya des sujets qui
devraient beaucoup plus mais qui manque
encore un week-end les gars that her 2
aujourd'hui il pourrait vouloir te voir
se tourner davantage
je pense qu'il y en a forcément mais
c'est assez difficile à dire fin de mon
point de vue je dirais bref beaucoup
plus de vulgarisation sur sciences de
l'éducation et la tenante parce que je
me rends compte de toute la littérature
qui affiche seulement d'une infime
partie mais c'est déjà énorme en
comparaison avec ce qui se fait en vrai
enfin chez moi je le verrais pas du tout
par exemple comme de la concurrence au
contraire comme une super opportunité
s'il ya de plus en plus de gens qui se
mettent à parler de ce sujet là et
j'essaie de réfléchir en termes un peu
de d'utilité sociale finalement je me
dis que parler d'éducation et rajouter
une dimension scientifique à l'éducation
aider les enseignants qui souvent des
conditions de travail pas ouf
et encore c'est un euphémisme qui ont
pas beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
nécessairement pour aller lire des
articles scientifiques
je me dis l'utilité que ça peut avoir
des riads si on améliore ne serait ce
que 2 5% l'heureux leurs pratiques
ou alors qu'on les aide à être plus à
l'aise dans leur travail du coup moins
fatigué à la fin la journée pape j'ai
l'impression que c'est un des endroits
on a un levier pour améliorer la société
changer le monde n'ayant pas peur des
mots à l'étagé plus grand et fin bon
donc moi je je je prêche pour ma
paroisse évidemment l'éducation mais je
pense qu'il y en a plein d'autres
auxquelles je pense pas nécessairement
sur les stèles besoin sociétal jeu je ne
sui te rejoins sur ce point en fait je
pense que c'est pas forcément une
histoire de dissiper mais par contre je
pense qu'on devrait traiter plus
peut-être de sujets société par exemple
cette période de retour à la nature
massif dans ses robes la phytothérapie
le mojo myopathies les gens faisaient
mal gamme savent pas trop à quoi ce qui
est pourquoi comment comment ça marche
et c'est donc ce serait le moment
d'utiliser toutes les sciences tourné à
disposition que ce soit de
l'épistémologie de la biologie de la
chimie
n'importe quoi pour leur expliquer et
leur donner des informations fiables et
concrètes sur un problème de société
parce que ça concerne final est donné
des infos aux gens qui ne savent pas où
aller chercher et faire le travail de
compiler ces infos de quantifier la
fiabilité de ses informations et
finalement de rendre les choses
accessibles aux gens qui ne ce qu'ils
n'ont même pas idée en toute bonne foi
de comment évaluer si la parole de
quelqu'un est plus pertinente que
d'autres personnes parce que la
légitimité des gens qui parlent en face
c'est un vrai problème quoi mais chut je
pense que l'opération
c'est qu'en fait les gens en dehors de
nos scientifiques en fait sous-estiment
beaucoup là la difficulté de donner
autant arriver à des conclusions
scientifiques général et la facilité
avec laquelle il désire voir
miser sur le mauvais williams en disiez
je pense que les chercheurs s'implique
pas trop dans les problèmes politiques
justement parce que ils sont confrontés
à l'étendue du nombre de questions qui
restent à élucider et du court toute
modestie se sentent pas la légitimité de
s'exprimer sur un sujet sur lequel ils
sont prêts pas à 8 millions de censure
alors que je maîtrise quand même le
sujet alors que d'autres gens écrire un
bouquin comme ça en étant monsieur tout
le monde d'avoir beaucoup de succès et
devenir l'expert mondial de du sujet là
et c'est là où le nombre d'infos
accessible un secteur protégé quelqu'un
en particulier mais maintenant la
légitimité de quelqu'un se fait par sa
notoriété et la notoriété ça dépend pas
forcément de la compétence des gens ni
de leur expertise dans un domaine
malheureusement donc le fait qu'elle
plusieurs sources qui traite d'une
problématique au train du plein de gens
différents qui aborde le même problème
va aider les gens à avoir plein d'infos
accessible qui vont eux mêmes semblent
c'est peut-être que ça changera quelque
chose je n'ai pas le j'espère pour
rebondir sur ce que tu dis il ya aussi
le fait que la science ya un côté ultra
ingrat finalement c'est à dire que d'une
barre ça prend beaucoup de temps c'est à
dire pour avoir des résultats
scientifiques
souvent ça se compte en années et
surtout qu avoir un résultat s'il faut
qu'il soit répliqué qu'ils aient
d'autres gens qui passent des études
pour être vraiment sûr c'est vrai
qu'ensuite on a une certaine prudence
par rapport à ce qu'on affirme alors que
d'autres personnes justement ne pas
cette prudence et du coup se c'est un
petit peu une contradiction qu'on peut
retrouver dans le milieu de la
vulgarisation de se demander au québec
d'un côté on sait qu'il faut parler de
certaines choses
d'un autre côté on prend le risque si on
parle trop vite d'un sujet ou qu'on
maîtrise pas assez on peut avoir un
petit peu ce sentiment d'imposture par
rapport à des choses qu'on maîtrise pas
forcément donc c'est pas évident je
pense de savoir où se situer est ce que
j'apprécie beaucoup chez certains
vulgarisateur comme l'est par exemple
sa maman lui jeter des
un petit peu cette posture de prudence
et d'être capable de dire il ya des
trucs je ne sais pas et je pense qu'il
ya même pour les par exemple il ya des
moments on oublie on on se trompe qu'on
affirme des trucs avec un petit peu trop
de certitudes même les moments
inoubliables
non mais c'est vraiment cette idée de
être capable de se rendre compte et de
d'expliciter le fait qu'on n'est pas sûr
qu'on a le droit de ne pas être sûr et
qu'on peut quand même dire des choses
intéressantes mais donc plutôt que
d'essayer à tout prix de convaincre
juste d'être capable ouais être
transparent sur qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on parle de recherche de quoi on
parle vraiment et bah oui on a des
doutes nous aussi on se pose des
questions et justement on n'a pas toutes
les réponses mais on partage cette
curiosité avec beaucoup de gens je pense
qu'ils nous écoutent qui nous regardent
et c'est cette curiosité finales
manquées au coeur de ce qu'on a envie de
partager avec les gens se posent des
questions qui on les partage ont partagé
nos réflexions et celle de beaucoup
d'autres chercheurs sont des enfants
curieux finalement et je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec toi il ya aussi le
fait que le public va pouvoir dans sa
globalité voir qu'une certaine quantité
d'or de vidéos par jour donc il ya une
quantité totale de vidéos qui peuvent
être vues un jour tout évidemment ne
sont pas de la vulgarisation
scientifique
mais du coup il ya quand même quelque
chose qui est important c'est que j'ai
appris pour une communauté qui
privilégie la qualité sur la quantité se
pose d'abord la question de quesques une
autre vidéo apporte c'est vraiment
d'aborder un angle de vue alors vous
chercher pour produire quelque chose qui
certes ne durera pas longtemps à la fin
mais qui va pas jouer justement sur la
quantité et enfin loppement que je
voulais aborder c'est pour répondre à ta
question je ne crois pas qu'il ya un
domaine qui fermera je veux pas
continuer à spéculer mais je crois pas
qu'il ya un domaine qui manque dans la
théorisation
par contre ce qui manque en général
parfaitement la vulgarisation mais dans
ce qui est communiqué sur la science au
grand public c'est la manière de faire
comme moi les choses sont produites
parce que souvent les contenus
scientifiques en tous cas à l'école sont
transmis de façon très dogmatique en
réalité c'est comme ça prenez votre
théorème appliquer votre théorème et du
coup les gens se font une vision près
force tous cas la science en réalité en
eaux vives à vrai dire il ya aussi le
fait que finalement les résultats sans
typique où ce que les gens imaginent et
la science finalement c'est la
technologie qu'il arrive donc c'est une
science qui est répond et de
problématiques parfois une urgence donc
il faut se dire on part d'une
conséquence et parfois mettre un petit
peu la prudence de côté que les gens
n'arrivent pas à voir si je fais je ne
sais pas si je fais un insecticide c'est
parce que je considère qu'il faut
détruire ce parasite pour pouvoir faire
donc je parle d'une hypothèse forte et
j'ai agi en conséquence
ce qui fait que la science arrive jamais
totalement nue au public est toujours au
bénin de marketing a enrobé d'un titre
de technologie de politique également
puisque la science elle a sa place
que ça soit dans l'écologie l'économie
plein de sujets qui sont purement
politique et donc effectivement tout le
passage de la construction de la science
la science qui se remet en doute qu'ils
évoluent et pas forcément bien
représentés du parc des technologies qui
sont mis en place pour qu'on a fait ça
avant ces apparts un peu de fille si ce
n'est donc le processus scientifique et
jamais tel qu'il apparaît dans les
sphères académique et c'est aussi ça qui
est au but un peu certains académiciens
c'est qu'ils ont l'impression de sortir
cette posture du scientifique se remet
en question et c'est pour prendre
position donc faire un acte politique en
réalité et donc pas beaucoup de
personnes sont capables d'être en accord
avec ces deux partis qu on a peut-être
une partie un petit peu hooligans dans
la manière d'agir
seulement à scientifique bilan
réflexivité total hockey d'autres mots
si je comprends bien dit il me trompe
nouveau tu suggères bug qui font
travailler un peu plus sur l'histoire
des sciences césar mais mal compris
c'est l'histoire des sciences après le
problème dès sa naissance c'est que elle
est à la fois jeudi à rodez sur les
bangers avec comme seul devant leur
public
c'est ça ne dépend de dépend quel est
l'objectif de la médiation si c'est pour
faire comprendre une notion faire
comprendre une notion plus profondément
de sa partie principe et par exemple la
chemise si je dis à quelqu'un tout de
suite que dans une oxydation n'a pas
besoin d'oxygène et à me regarder
bizarrement
donc là on est obligé de comprendre
l'histoire pour pouvoir parce qu'on a
étudié l'oxygène ensuite m'a compris
réellement ce code est l'oxygène donc on
a généralisé
il ya plein de définition qui on se rend
partie précise mme intelligence
artificielle les domaines évolue
constamment
après il ya un domaine qui évolue très
rapidement c'est par exemple la loi
c'est les postures réglementaires etc
elle vous jeu très très peu par rapport
aux définitions ce qui se passe dans le
milieu académique et donc ça a créé des
dégâts
donc l'histoire est toujours bonne
conseillère mais ça nécessite de prendre
son temps et d'accompagner dans le rôle
des médiateurs des mégalithes heures
c'est de l'accompagner cueillies dans
cet aspect l'histoire pour pas partir
parce que l'histoire devient très
compliqué aussi linéaire qu'on l'apprend
sur les prises chronologique des manu ex
alors moi j'aimerais faire reculer je te
bats comme le temps que la communauté
d'affaires histoire du débat c'est ça
non
un en train de se demander la cie
domaine sifflets de médiateurs mais
imaginons nous coupant internet et nous
faisons disparaître tous ces gens
l'action de cette pièce par un
claquement de doigts comme dans un film
familial bien des papouilles à internet
était très peu développés où il est
peintre
ces médiateurs et ça fonctionnait mal
pourquoi pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé
presque là on comble un vide est ce
qu'avant c'était c'était de no man's
land
qu'est ce qui se passait avant qu'on
existe et qu'il s'agisse du mal à sortir
il ya deux choses en fait c'est que
avant qu'internet arrive
les médias étaient beaucoup plus
verticaux donc les les contenus qui a
été présenté ça ne se prive pas
forcément de l'atelier théâtre étaient
contenus documentaires etc
il était beaucoup moins discutée par la
population s'est tu recevais passivement
l'information alors que maintenant
l'information il est beaucoup plus
débattues et les beaucoup plus digérer
ce qui peut donner des communautés de
complotisme des communautés ces petits
comme etc mais le rapport à
l'information a changé et l'autre chose
qui a changé avec internet c'est la
quantité d'informations disponibles ces
mêmes avant l'information était beaucoup
plus rare c'est encore plus le cas avant
la télévision continue à remonter comme
ça mais moi pas où je fais monter des
gens qu'on dit qu'on était au collège et
au lycée sans wikipédiens c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui a changé ma vie ex
j'aurais donné énormément quand j'étais
petit pour avoir accès au wi qui peut
dire et mais a contrario le fait qu'on a
accès à autant d'informations signifie
qu'on doit être beaucoup plus capable de
la filtrer de la traiter efficacement et
c'est pour ça je pense que maintenant il
ya une demande croissante sur la méthode
sur comment à comment justement l'esprit
critique
oui ça 2
l'esprit critique et être capable de
pouvoir non seulement s'interroger sur
le contenu de pouvoir remonter aux
sources de pouvoir croiser les sources
de pouvoir accéder deux pour se poser
des questions sur les sources qu'on
reçoit et des capable du coup de
partager de façon encore plus consciente
en fait les choses de façon à ce que ce
soit pas les contenus les plus faciles à
partager les plus émotifs qui vont se
diffuser
qu'on soit pas noyé penser conclut la
rencontre des contenus qu'ils puissent
être validée collectivement comme c'est
le cas par exemple sur wikipédia mais
une citation du manoir et qui gros
quelque chose comme ça par coeur mais
pas sur d'autres questions j'ai pas
besoin de faire des situations qui dire
un truc du genre
avant on sait qu'avant la narration
étaient rares et celui qui avait le
pouvoir à celui qui possédait cette
information qu'il a gardé pour lui alors
que désormais celui qui va avoir le plus
de pouvoir plus de capacité d'influencé
celui qui l'est davantage t'as pas de
nom pas d'avoir informations mais deux
rejeté tout ce qui est en partie pour
répondre qu'est ce qui se faisait avant
finalement c'est internet a plus
accéléré je trouve des diffusions de
savoir accélérer des échanges sociaux
qui existait déjà mais qu'ils étaient
plus difficiles parce que ça on était
venu le temps de transférer d'un an sont
anodines et pour dans l'histoire ya
toujours une a vu la réalisation au sein
de public par exemple les normes aimant
de choses en chimie c'était chaque
professeur qui avait un petit peu son
cabinet de curiosités où c'est
présentation cours etc
donc il y avait plusieurs professeurs
dans les villes mais il fallait faire
venir son épaisseur les livres étaient
très cher donc du coup on à diminuer les
coûts de diffusion de savoir alors ça a
rendu la science des projets
collaboratifs wikipedia très fin le plus
facile à faire mais c'est aussi permis à
des communautarismes de pouvoir aussi
s'accélérer renfermé aussi donc est-ce
que c'est pire
qu'avant oui et non c'est juste mon a
accéléré un mouvement qui était déjà
sous jacent mais beaucoup plus lent et
moins perspective de perceptive en tout
cas l'impression que j'ai en écoutant
évidemment loin et les épines c'est que
c'est quand même un domaine qui sort
émerger ce que vous allez dire je vois
ces technologies l'accent sur coruscant
16 conseils de mon chant typique ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose que comme
beaucoup de gens ont l'impression de
devoir mettre plus en avant qu'avant et
on peut être que c'est le domaine sur
lequel je pense qu'il ya un souci et je
pense que vraiment ce qui ferait avancer
les choses c'est que les gens
comprennent qu'on recherche c'est comme
disait plein c'est pour les mamans de
temps mais je pense qu'on a là deux
vitesses il ya la réalité de commencer
la science aujourd'hui
donc comme on sait qui est dans une
situation assez désastreuse possible a
pas d'argent mais ça prend beaucoup de
temps et que c'est très compliqué et en
même temps quand il ya une découverte
scientifique les médias et le fait qu'il
est en information tout le temps on veut
souvent du oui ou du non c'est du blanc
du noir alors que c'est rarement ça on
se rend compte des fois que découverte
va être modifiée on va revenir sur ce
qu'on savait pas ce que les analyses ont
été poussé plus avant parce que notre
équipe a trouvé quelque chose et je
pense que pour le grand public c'est
très compliqué enfin ils se disent avoir
une mais à il ya deux ans nous a dit
l'un d'eux du coup scientifique sur
n'importe quoi et ça se passe qu'ils
font mais c'est parce qu'ils vont voir
que l'on désire aller cherche des poids
ita tornade et fois avec ça c'est pas
trop comment faire et je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment essayé de faire un peu
la lumière et le point sur cette
différence entre ce que l'on transmet au
grand public genre c'est tout noir c'est
tout blanc et la réalité des choses et
ça c'est très compliqué parce que je ne
dis pas que les médias sont mauvais loin
de là on voit les quelques fois où j'ai
été confronté aux médias ça s'est plutôt
bien passé mais il ya vraiment ces deux
vitesses quoi et c'est je pense que
c'est important de d'apporter de la
nuance et du détail sur ce genre de
choses c'est aussi habituer peut-être
les gens réfléchir en terme
bah et puis il en dire que oui c'est pas
ben oui c'est pas donc on peut être dans
du de la nuance sans que ce soit
forcément une mauvaise chose que de voir
quasiment transitionner à la tribune
donc yohann thuram était quelque chose
quelque chose excuse moi oui il ya aussi
autre chose qui est apparu c'est que le
rapport
la chaîne de communication des
informations scientifiques a beaucoup
évolué parce que avant tu avais le
chercheur qui sortait ses publications
qui après pouvait être en reprise par
l'université qui envoyait sa à des
dépêches d'information qui ensuite après
été reprises dans des journaux
secondaire qui après seulement étaient
diffusés dans les grands médias car ça
faisait de longues chaînes alors que
maintenant il ya quelque chose de d'un
peu étrange quelque part par rapport au
modèle précédent qui est que le
chercheur s'il veut devenir
vulgarisateur peut communiquer
directement ou le chercheur solliciter
un vulgarisateur pour communiquer à sa
place quelque part le la médiation entre
le chercheur et le public lui-même est
devenu vachon plus courte la chaîne est
devenu ma passion plus courte et ça pose
à la fois la question du coup peut-être
que le signal sera moins brouillée entre
l'émetteur et du récepteur mais aussi
peut-être que ça offre la possibilité
aux chercheurs de faire passer beaucoup
plus des points de vue personnel et ça
peut donner une grosse importance
justement à la vulgarisation donc à la
communication s'enticher pour certains
qui peuvent être détournés et exprimer
des choses qui pourraient naître au
personnel est trop éloigné du consensus
scientifique troisième trouvé pour créer
nos sections semés çà mais notre
question que je voulais poser d'autres
coulées passé en l'autre question c'est
mon plan initial c'est qu'est ce que
j'en sais que vous faites mal en
particulier que vous pourriez me faire
dans votre bulle des relations moins au
début j'avais commencé à faire pour
introduire des concepts mathématiques
j'ai pensé par exemple a parlé de
l'école ionienne au talent etc et je me
suis rendu je me suis rendu compte
je disais dans mes vidéos je ne suis pas
un historien rappelez vous en mais le
simple fait de le dire ne suffit pas en
place et le travail d'historien et j'ai
fait par me rendre compte que j'ai au
début je voulais beaucoup plus source et
mes documents et je parlais de
mathématiques et histoire mathématiques
je peux faire les preuves moi-même et
histoire bien comme j'étais pas
historien je n'étais pas très au fait de
des documents historiques dont je me
retrouvais à faire des vidéos
vulgarisation qui était très pauvre en
ressources en réalité ce qui me chagrine
beaucoup donc depuis j'ai essayé
d'améliorer beaucoup plus de citer
beaucoup plus de sources d'apporter des
vidéos complémentaires 10 ou qui parlent
de sujets ou des paquets carrément qui a
pas de sujets complémentaires
mais quand on traite d'un sujet comme la
mathématique ou de sujets commettre
connexes comme par exemple la
mathématique à l'antiquité qui est
connexe avec l'histoire
on peut se retrouver à être en dehors de
son domaine d'expertisé avoir des
problèmes a justifié correctement ça
veut dire évasion de base on n'est pas
forcément jeu suivant amené à faire
attention au fait que l'on a évité
d'autres domaines d'expertisé technique
cette différence est de même pour la
philosophie on peut traiter de sujets de
philosophie sans pour autant avoir une
formation et donc on peut se retrouver à
dire des bêtises moi ce que je fais mal
c'est je parle trop vite et je mets trop
d'infos dans mes vidéos
moi j'essaie d'améliorer parce que
justement il ya trop de vidéos jambes
donc d'où je sortais frustré c'est vrai
que ça c'est en un sens et une qualité
parce que
les gens apprennent beaucoup mais le
problème c'est que le message peut-être
est brouillée et pourquoi en arriver à
cette conclusion c'est ok d'arrivée de
tes vidéos du tennis et ses commentaires
les commentaires vous pouvez en prendre
moi je n'ai pas beaucoup mais pas cru
quand leur soit bien au dessus il suffit
d'un commentaire pour savoir le temps
question csu 17 au 27 mai avec le chien
qu'est-ce qu'il avait d'autres
autocritique
disons que j'ai l'impression que c'est
un défaut qui est partagé par énormément
de personnes passionnées par leur
deuxième c'est que emporté par la foule
a envie de donner normes et manque
d'information des choses qui me font
plaisir de faire des vidéos qu'on aurait
aimé revoir mais qui sont pas forcément
les attentes qu'on notre public ils
veulent avoir donc les coudes du public
et écouter ses retours et très
intéressante
on a énormément fait d'intervention
publique et c'est pourquoi il ya
énormément de personnes qu'il adore les
interventions publiques pour avoir cet
échange est de voir est ce que la chose
fonctionne ou pas davantage en atelier
ces j'ai rarement fait un atelier
exactement de la même façon avec donner
exactement à l'idéal explication parce
que j'ai pas du tout le même public
en face de moi donc c'est aussi ça c'est
un prendre un petit peu le recul c'est
que je ne transmet pas la science parce
que j'adore les nations c'est aussi
parce que j'aime faire comprendre la
science et donc il faut que je fasse un
effort de langage il faut que je fasse
un effort
justement que ce soit aussi un échange
réciproque qui autant de choses à
apprendre au public en leur donnant des
informations mais ils ont autant de
chances de choses à me donner eux de
leur façon de comprendre leur façon de
saisir ce savoir et qu'est ce qu'ils en
font donc il ya aussi tout un aspect
écoute du public est tout aussi
intéressant de travailler sur soi et de
faire ces sources
les sources c'est intéressant mais aussi
après il faut les expliquer si on parle
le médiateur scientifique ces finales
on est une interface et on est à
l'écouté des uns des autres
donc faire un petit peu a dit est un
dandy peu le feu que certes j'aurais
voulu parler de ça j'aurais aimé ça mais
si on arrive à faire renaître
juste une petite étincelle de curiosité
que concept soit compris et utiliser ces
boues politique de vouloir faire
introduire notation qui ne est certes
très belle formellement mais qui
actuellement dans le monde les
spectateurs me servira donc le pipe par
l'ajac un petit peu cette histoire de
curiosité est ce que cela avait beaucoup
parlé d'eux des choses qui sont très
très médiatique on va dire de pouvoir
actuel moi je pensais me sers de votre
combat qui est important c c c susciter
davantage de curiosité du grand public
ça marchera pas forcément très bien
court termine sur une hauteur de nancy
l'autocritique hockey pot-au-feu grand
manager et des milliers de trucs à dire
je pense que pour faire du pièce que
vient de dire heureux le point suivant
est important sur lequel pendant
l'essentiel de ma carrière de vidéastes
youtuber ça a été de définir dans le
monde public cible enfin pas de le
définir
mais de vraiment m'adapter en fonction
de lui est en fait le problème c'est que
en france à plus de 800 mille
enseignants et la réalité entre
enseignants en maternelle enseignants à
la fac par exemple et pas forcément la
même déjà avoir le public aussi large
pas forcément évidente à un public cible
aussi l'âge c'est pas forcément évident
savoir à qui je regrette vraiment et en
fait je pense que mes vidéos s'adressait
pas tant aux enseignants dans le sens où
je répondais pas à leurs problématiques
de base donc avant d'amener la science
comme
j'ai pu vouloir le faire peut-être que
ce serait mieux de commencer par savoir
quelles sont leurs problématiques les
questions que se posent leurs
difficultés et d'essayer par cet aspect
là par cet angle de leurs leurs
problématiques essayer d'apporter un
petit peu la science et les éléments
scientifiques qui peuvent résoudre cette
problématique
je trouve que un truc que je fait très
mal c'est ouais m'adapter à mon public
si elle pense qu'il faudrait faire pour
mieux connaître et une saveurs question
du problème n'est pas ce que tu as des
interactions avec des enseignements
heureusement oui et c'est aussi pour ça
que je sais que je fais pas super bien
anglo fin après voilà c'est toujours
difficile parce que j'ai des retours
d'enseignants qui adore et qui trouve ça
très bien et très chouette mais ça reste
que je suis conscient j'ai un certain
nombre de sujets où je sais que ça
répond plus aux problématiques des
enseignants est à la fois j'ai plusieurs
dizaines probablement plus d'une
centaine de sujets en attente et sachant
qu'une vidéo ça prends moi ça me prend
entre 50 et 100 heures en moyenne pour
une vidéo 5 10 minutes
je peux juste pas tout traiter du coup
c'est toujours la question de la
difficulté de parcours on commence mais
en vrai oui je suis en interaction à la
fois avec des chercheurs à la fois avec
des enseignants et je vais l'être de
plus en plus y compris dans mes travaux
de recherche justement à réfléchir et à
faire la recherche sur l'interface entre
lui et la recherche et les enseignants
donc je pense que plus le temps va
passer j'ai aussi avoir des réponses à
ces questions là de quelles sont les
problématiques des choses sur lesquelles
je pouvais vraiment aider concrètement
mais en même temps ça reste la
difficulté de si c'est pas un angle moi
je maîtrise nécessairement le sujet où
je savais pas forcément comment
l'aborder bien je peux être privilégié
un sujet que je l'entrisme donc et je
sais pas et encore une fois sa chance
la communauté des enseignants ce
finalement temps pas de communauté
peut-être un peu différente répondre aux
problématiques de personnes sur le dans
le milieu de la petite enfance par
exemple doit pas forcément être
directement utiles à d'autres personnes
qui font des formations
des parents qui se posent des questions
pour le radeau change donc voilà ça
reste ça reste une problématique
complexe et puis on veut voir façon je
fais ça bénévolement donc je m'amuse
aussi c'est compliqué parce que j'ai pas
vraiment un format spécifique de
vulgarisation oui je fais la différence
du coup j'ai des défauts dans tous les
autres quel est le défaut comme moi tout
ce que tu veux
j'organise des trucs logistique et je
crois que le principal problème c'est
que j'ai pas assez de temps parce que je
fais encore de la recherche à côté du
coup je me cherche le jour et je me le
dis à reese la nuit mais des fois c'est
un peu short vraiment de sens voilà mais
en fait ouais c'est bien d'avoir
conscience de ses défauts et ses limites
et que l'on pourra toujours faire mieux
et on pourra toujours toucher plus de
gens et on pourra toujours faire des
trucs mieux et tant qu'on est dans cette
optique là on a eu juste de s'améliorer
et savent à quoi bon en particulier de
d'amélioration d'amélioration plus que
le temps consacré à chaque chose pour
vraiment là réfléchir et la formaliser
et prendre le temps techniquement on
améliorer parce que voilà je découvre le
son en même temps que je découvre le
podcast je découvre la vidéo au moment
où je rencontre baby des dvds fin c'est
tout un processus à apple a plein de
compétences transversales que j'ai pas
en tant que chercheuse et que je dois
apprendre je dois m'améliorer dans tous
ouais ce que j'avais en face de moi ce
que je regarde agressé ma rédaction
ça se voit mais du coup en fait je dois
vulgariser des passages de sens aux
milliers de 2,2 d'histoire en fait moi
ya la guerre il ya une trame narrative
est dedans je doit inclure en fait des
passages de vulgarisation et donc au
niveau de la rédaction bas il faut pas
être trop formels parce que je vois la
preuve que ça là c'est naturel et en
même temps j'aime bien que relativement
détaillées relativement précis et donc
du coup oui j'ai toujours du mal à
sacrifier sacrifie des points
scientifique pour des pointes de
narration est donc en fait c'est gérer
cette étude ça prend énormément de temps
et j'avoue que moi j'aimerais bien ils
passaient moins d'énergie que
m'améliorer si je pouvais y passer moins
de temps et d'énergie et pouvoir
fasciste
puis sophie cadieux
ouais être un peu plus efficace là
dessus heureusement du coup j'ai des
gens qui m'aident à la fac ironise un
peu ce que je fais pour pouvoir me dit
t'es quoi parce que enfin si difficile
d'avoir un regard enfin vraiment un
regard critique sur ce qu'on a fait
surtout quand on ya passé plusieurs
alfonsi booba j'espère que cette fois ça
va aller et en fait ça va surpasser
difficile mais j'espère qu'à force je
vais apprendre surtout à gérer cet
équilibre vraiment entre la précision
scientifique et puis elle à la
naturalité du discours en fait ouais
j'avais fait ses exercices jarry veux
pas penser imaginer comment fermer
moi je pense que ça rejoint ce qui est
plusieurs points déjà abordé j'ai
tendance quand je quand moi spectatrice
je veux apprendre un truc que j'ai envie
de tout savoir sur le truc en question
donc j'aime bien quand y'a plein de
sources
j'ai envie de connaître l'origine du
truc on parle d'un phénomène j'aime bien
un petit peu d'histoire des sciences sur
ce truc là j'ai envie de savoir
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on sait et
c'est ce qui fait que donc moi c'est
surtout à la base c'était du blog
illustré et depuis peu chez l'un radio
et je sais que par exemple les articles
blogs
alors j'ai peu de retour parce que c'est
la malédiction du blog c'est que
maintenant des gens prennent plus trop
le temps commenté dessus donc je sais
pas qui de l'eau liquide public esther
mais quelques retours que j'ai c'est
souvent c'est trop c'est trop long donc
moi je suis toujours frustré parce que
vous dit amélie mais là je te parle d'un
livre le passe juste te dire il est bien
à chaque fois il faut que présente de
quoi ça parle
donc moi j'ai envie de détailler mais
des images parce que c'est important
tout ça donc j'ai envie d'en mettre une
tartine
je pense qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont
mis trois buts et s'il ya de la longueur
donc voilà et même chose pour la radio
au départ on va se mettre à dos étaient
trente minutes et les faîtages crash
fait 4e 30 minutes et toutes les autres
ont entre 45 et 48 qui donc que j'ai
largement déportés le créneau mais
pareil derrière un quart d'heure sur
internet 30 bat c'est quand même un tir
de broder et parce que pareil tu vois je
n'ai pas envie de balancer une anecdote
comme ça elle ne pas expliquer d'où ça
sort etc
alors j'imagine que ça permettait de
pareil j'ai peu de retour donc je ne
sais pas ce qu'en pensent les gens c'est
mon autocritique sur moi même tu penses
que tu vas faire douter que à nouveau
trempée choix moi j'aime bien faire tout
ce que ce soit plus long plus détaillée
mais je sais pas quel point ça rebute
les aider les gens qui écoutent
est ce qu'il préfère un truc le cours
qui va plus directement au point
vrai ou pas ça assez de retour encore
puisque ça que j'ai plus d'expérience je
pense après ce défaut là c'est aussi ce
que j'aime
du côté là pas sur la scène et hors
scène du la re lecture c'est que je suis
face à la multiplicité de vidéastes de
professionnels qui eux n'ont pas les
mêmes communautés les mêmes objectifs
donc pas les mêmes exigences
donc bon après moi je suis plutôt de la
team vraiment pinailleur méfie
d'ailleurs vraiment le meilleur parce
que le vraiment être sûr que finn est la
personne la personne lorsqu'elle fait un
choix de médiation parce que c'est
vraiment un choix on ne peut pas tout
dire dans un temps défini donc c'est
vraiment un choix éditorial de choisir
je vais aborder plus tôt ça le présentée
de cette façon mais il faut quand même
s'assurer que le médiateur qui fait
cette approximation
est ce que c'est on va dire c'est un des
commentaires classique lorsqu'on reçoit
oui mais c'est pas totalement sas en
fait c'est plus précis de sa série
tiennent alors moi aussi j'adore être
pinailleur mais c'est un exercice et on
peux pas te fasse on ne pourra pas tout
dit et redit financer à court de
diversité c'est un cours n'a pas
forcément eu envie d'avoir rire en plus
pour ceux qui sont sur les formats pour
les collégiens viscères ils ont déjà des
cours à prendre dans un système beaucoup
plus formel donc si c'est pour avoir
exactement et du coup ils vont pas être
intéressé ce qui fait que lorsque par
typiquement dr nous même lorsqu'il fait
un pas raison que j'ai cités mc format
qui le vrai ou faux lorsqu'il à ces
informations et qu'on me demande de
relire ce qui le dit je m'assure quand
même que sache que la piste qui l'a
explorée celle une parmi d'autres de
façon que si par exemple quelqu'un
interroge dans les commentaires sur
pourquoi n'as tu pas parler de ça
10 j'ai eu connaissance de ça j'ai
choisi pas l'inclure mais c'est un
exercice ce qui est très délicat donc
c'est ça aussi que j'aime entendre les
couleurs c'est de voir comment les
autres personnes font leurs choix
éditoriaux et cissé sur d'inspiration de
voir aussi comment les autres fonctions
adaptées en leur sein et c'est aussi
pour ça que j'aime cette ambiance de
retraite du café pour voir se rencontrer
échanger sur comment on fait la
médiation parce qu'on a énormément
apprendre des autres et comme on a un
format tous différents et qui a pas une
réponse universelle en est finalement
sur des publics assez différent aux
attentes différentes
donc c'est une inspiration perpétuel et
c'est pas une n'est pas une science
exacte mais du coup tu y aurait que tu
n'as trop bas après c'est le problème de
la chimie qui est vraiment quelque chose
de très formel et on nous le reproche
beaucoup situés n'importe quelle
étiquette de shampoing tu vas voir tous
nos noms chimiques à l'onf en 5 lignes
seul composé mes cd formalisme pour une
raison après qu'on peut expliciter c'est
donc un seul nom soit unique pour un
seul proposé qu'à un seul nom et qui est
la parfaite déjections sont donc il ya
des explications pourquoi monde est
formel pour qu'on utilise aussi c'est le
mans terre etc
j'aime bien le formalisme et en est un
peu tous rassurés dans le formalisme on
va pas s'en cacher le fond des traces et
une sécurité
je mets café astro de la définition donc
mes résultats vont être bons
je m'éclate patronaux moderne les
apprentis passionnant que les hypothèses
sont plutôt jolis et fonctionne bien
c'est pas le monde réel et la
vulgarisation public est aussi un monde
réel dans des approximations et le
formalisme c'est pas fait pour eux alors
je vais revenir faire notre truc qui
disait d'alarmé booker lancement c'est
la retraite du café j'ai aussi à
rassembler autant de moments du café des
sciences po skarsgard et le micro ce que
j'ai posé une question difficile
je veux qu'on passe du coup on est là
pour pas pour partager nos c'est
d'apprendre les uns des autres et pour
que les autres apprennent de nous il
faut qu'on dise ce qu'on pense qu'à
faire du coup la licence c'est qu'est ce
que vous pensez faire mieux que les
autres membres du café des sciences
yokoyama est il mieux que tous les
autres et loire une coming après au
moins indirecte loisirs tu vas beaucoup
de défauts sont voici des qualités enfin
quelles sont les qualités
vraiment je dois dire ma présence on va
dire si j'ai une principale qualité
c'est ma disponibilité
c'est à dire que si quelqu'un à une
question et même si elle est aussi bête
que ce soit et par ma tante est toujours
ouverte et lutte c'est vraiment pas ma
qualité c'est que je me vois pas comme
un relecteur tel un professeur de classe
où certains chercheurs qui vraiment vous
donnez un article où laurent corriger en
rouge avec des rats partout c'est ça
qu'il faut dire donc moi je donne mes
explications mes explications tu fais ce
que tu veux mais je devrai prévenu le
but c'est toujours d'avoir cette
bienveillance envers les personnes qui
viennent nous voir parce qu'ils ont
leurs doutes leurs prêts conception et
même nous dp conception quand quelqu'un
vient de voir le domaine donc le but
c'est d'avoir quand même l'écoutent de
ces personnes est respectée aussi leur
point de vue et leur manière de faire
qui sont pas forcément du coup
disponibilité bienveillance et écoute
ces trois d'entre elles ont été
nombreuses la jemmerais pourra le rester
tout bac alors
la grande qualité j'ai à peine le fait
mieux que les autres ce que je fais bien
je pensais mettre à la place des gens
qui le grand chose parce que je ne sais
pas grand chose et des boues ça me
permet de mieux expliquer comme en même
temps que je comprends mes sujets que
j'aborde du coup tu tu réfléchis ce que
tu écris aussi que tu réfléchis à parce
que l'autre bas l'autre c'est moi
en fait tu devrais je bosse je réécris
20 permanence tant que tant que je suis
pas satisfait tant que je sais que ce
que j'ai écrit
c'est pas honnête je recommence non
parce que y'a des fois des passages qui
sont plus que des raccourcis de
l'approximation qui sont plutôt des
entourloupes les astuces pour dire je
n'ai pas très bien compris mais oublions
le et tant qu'il ya des passages comme
ça qui reste je pense que j'ai la
capacité de les détecter et du coup de
les améliorer de l'échangé pour vraiment
que tout soit clair ce qui d'ailleurs
est alors très stimulant pendant la
rédaction
mais quand j'arrive à la fin du texte et
c'est frustrant parce que je mets la
pression contexte est d'une simplicité
est navrante
il m'a dit mais c'est pas possible que
je vais passer un mois là dessus le
texte a l'air très simple très basique
et non en fait c'est pas pour rien qu'il
ait l'air aussi simple et basique c'est
que vraiment pourquoi en arriver là il a
fallu le marché le redis vie réelle
comme bosch voilà donc peut-être que ma
qualité c'est sympa d'avoir davantage de
cette expérience que j'ai fait ça après
j'ai jamais vu passer une conversation à
ce sujet avec ta ville doit près de deux
ans une personne que j'apprécie
grandement parce qu'il a trop mais aussi
mac et quelquefois de bons conseils et
qui disait que attention en vie alors
c'est bien de dire que ça c'est un
avantage que que les gens quand ils
n'ont pas expert c'est comme ça c'est
pas dur pour eux de se mettre à la place
de ceux qui savent pas mais il ya aussi
un goût amer ou en communion c'est que
on peut faire des ex proxy nation que
l'espère ne serait pas dangereux mais
grâce au café des sciences qui a un
comité de relecteur hors pair ces
défauts parce que tu a développé des
astuces pour essayer de mieux cibler les
parties où il ya potentiellement non
c'est purement instinctif
si mon astuce c'est de penser absolument
tout texte sur ce quand je suis au
travail bien sûr
enfin gros quand j'ai un moment de libre
j'aurais passe ça m'arrive des fois
avant de dormir et de de décrire le
texte mentalement
ouais là c'est là où arrivent les
meilleurs trucs
le problème c'est que je me suis
toujours pas résolu la mettant à dos et
un stylo et une feuille sur la table de
nuit
des fois je trouve des idéations
extraordinaire et je les oublie même un
matin je ne peux pas je sais que vous
que ce que je voulais en venir rêver de
ces épisodes la série mais voilà c'est
tout le temps sans doute une obsession
donc ça c'est moi je sais que ça reste
une tâche de fond comme je suis très
très lent mais d'une lenteur
exceptionnelle rester du coût de chaque
moment de répit que j'ai consacré à
penser à ce texte qui me donne tellement
de filles d'à rod laver les gens il ya
quand même pas mal de gens seraient
surpris qui se rend compte mais de
l'écriture du texte comme c'est
tellement grosse partie du travail fdt
attention c'est tout l'important quand
on fait des youtube que je regardais
tutorial est simple truc à faire
continue et une chaîne youtube c'est
bien le truc c'est important c'est le
contenu ils ont donc l'écriture et ça
c'est tellement important s'apprend tel
montant
difficile j'en dirais aussi des
animations mais on va garder ça j'ai un
peu le même problème s'était alors je
passe beaucoup de temps à rédiger à
faire à refaire à rechercher parce que
en fait il ya un compromis dans ce cas
un but égalisateur peut faire entre le
fait de traduire unis des scientifiques
de façon juste et de la traduire d'une
façon qui sera recevable pour l'auditeur
est souvent on fait un compromis est en
fait moi j'essaie de le faire le moins
possible parce que c'est un compromis
qui me déplaît profondément et de vous
ce que j'essaie de faire c'est un
revenant je recherche beaucoup je
retravaille et caetera et du coup je
mets dans mes textes qu'une partie de ce
que j'ai travaillé mais du coup si un
concept que je sais qu'il sera pas
abordable d'un bloc
j'essaie toujours de le sub divisé
subdiviser se mobiliser l'un combien de
ça c'est que du coup je me retrouve avec
une planification de vidéos à faire
notamment monstrueuse mais mais du coup
j'essaie de faire en sorte que ce que je
dis c'est vraiment ce que je pense au
mot près en fait j'ai fais gaffe au mot
près la virgule près ouais en externat
suprême n'est pas le le deuxième point
que je sais qu'elle je suis
particulièrement fier dans ce que je
fais c'est que plutôt que de présenter
une vidéo sous la forme je fais un
contenu à part un espèce de couronnes
cours magistral mais avec du rythme
j'essaie toujours de faire sous forme de
dialogue gg j'ai reçu une grande claque
quand j'étais ado en découvrant les
tests jédir de socrate mais bon c'est
compliqué mais le cette idée de dialogue
que qu'en fait tu construis le contenu
de la conversation à deux c'est quelque
chose de co construit et qui en plus
permet d'intégrer le point de vue du sel
chambre aussi le point de vue de la
personne qui est légitimement se poser
question donc l'armée à la fois de te
critiquer et à la fois de faire la
transition vers la suite ou de soulever
des points qui sont valides et je me
suis aperçu que faire un dialogue
c'était trois fois plus dur comme juste
de rédiger
et que c'était aussi en terme pas
seulement en termes de rythme et en
termes de contenu pachoud plus riches et
du coup je fais ça avec ma compagne et
du coup on fait comme ça des dialogues
moi face caméra elle hors champ et c'est
comme ça avec des épisodes sont
structurés faut pas que je faisais ça à
l'écrire dans mon blog à cette question
réponse est non je n'ai pas fait mais
moi mais ça c'est vraiment vraiment été
un peu la question fait souvent bien
réfléchir avec l'art il approche
dialectique ça aide beaucoup à ce qu'il
paraît je fais des montres et rémy palet
à la reconstitution mais davos
bon c'est super réaliste c'est ce que
les gens nous disent en fait on dirait
que je suis j'ai enfin je suis assez
contente quand on dit ça parce que si
c'est vraiment le but c'est de
l'immerger les gens dont elle veut
désormais par leur expliquer quelque
chose mais vraiment les emmener dans ce
moment ils auraient voilà c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
ouais ça finalement je prends affirment
les personnes à faire ça parce que c'est
super difficile d'amener les gens dans
l'ambiance du labo et ouais et du coup
j'avoue quand les gens me disent en fait
j'ai l'impression d'y être comme
pianiste quand ils disent maintenant que
la page était en tête et mon but ça
voudra pas vraiment l'époque où 80 s par
en bas là je vous dis j'ai vraiment
réussi à faire ce que je voulais et donc
voilà ça ça sera très clairement tuer ça
mieux que n'importe lequel d'entre eux
pensent que le sans conteste tout le
monde sera d'accord dans la retrait du
café des sciences pour dire que je fais
la meilleure tiramisu ouais ça c'est
assez consensuel je suis rendu le 6 je
peux négocier pour dire que je fais les
meilleurs chapeau aussi j'aurais
peut-être un petit peu de concurrence
bref maintenant blague à part
je pense que le jeu peut être un
avantage que je peux avoir c'est que
comme je fais de la recherche et julie
sur beaucoup de recherches en éducation
est aussi un côté un peu mais tu as
c'est à dire dans la réflexion sur la
vulgarisation parce que il ya un côté
éducatif adapté de l'habitation
donc ça peut m'être utile pour justement
maximiser on va dire un potentiel
d'apprentissage mais en vrai c'est pas
du tout nécessaire c'est à dire il ya
des tas de vulgarisateur qui font ça
mieux que moi et quand jamais lu un
article dans l'éducation
donc ouais je compte pas faire grand
chose de mieux que n'importe qui
peut-être plus que je fais mieux c'est
peut-être ma persévérance a continué
malgré les erreurs la rage est de gérer
ce qu'est un truc en particulier que tu
as lu dans un article
cette question et que d'appliquer une
vidéo je pense que tous les trucs sur
l'importance de la répétition de faire
des synthèses tout ça j'ai appliqué dans
certaines vidéos
après je dirais je ne me souviens pas je
pense que je devrais plus lire des
articles sur comment renforcer ma
mémoire pour répondre à tous non je ne
sais pas trop c'est à dire qu'il ya des
articles julie qui vont qui peuvent
influencer qui vont influencer
évidemment nue derrière je dirais que
c'est plus en une posture générale que
je peux avoir vis-à-vis de la
vulgarisation
on a peut-être assez facilement tendance
à prendre des trucs comme aux pommes
évitant et où je vais peut-être remettre
en question c'est évident justement
parce que ce sont des sujets qui sont
traités par l'éducation et donc je me
dire non mais est-ce que ça oui je le
crois mais est ce que c'est vrai est ce
qu'il n'ya pas justement de la
littérature scientifique sur le fut un
bon exemple là dessus c'est sûr l'esprit
critique va mal et à peu près tout le
monde en fait qu'il parle d esprit
critique où il faut développer l'esprit
critique et tout ça
puis là après avoir fait plusieurs mois
de recherches là dessus avec des vrais
chercheurs
je me suis rendu compte que c'est ultra
compliqué qu'il ya des tas de choses
super intéressantes qui ont été écrites
sur le sujet
en fait c'est pas du tout consensuelle
de ce qu'on entend par développer
l'esprit critique et c'est important
justement d'être conscient que c'est
très vague et que ça veut rien dire
à moins de le préciser et ça peut être
d'autant plus utile de le diviser en
deux traits qu'un petit peu plus précis
et voilà je pense que la ch'tite
l'esprit critique et on pourrait dire la
même chose de la démarche scientifique
et que le fait de très loin d'être le
seul ni même de médias le fait de
s'intéresser à l'épistémologie à la
façon dont ce fond les sciences je dis
bien les sciences po ce que les
différences énormes entre par exemple
comment on fait de la recherche en
mathématiques ou en biologie cellulaire
ou en éducation et donc avoir conscience
d'un petit peu de
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
cette réflexion sur ce qu'on est en
train de faire je pense est important et
je fais partie des personnes qui hachent
pense pas mal d'importance
du coup c'est pas un truc que je fais
mieux que les autres mais que j'ai la
chance d'avoir sais que j'ai un parcours
scientifique donc pareil j'ai appris à
lire des études je sais comment la
recherche fonctionne donc c'est vrai que
ça donne accès à des informations que
certaines personnes n'ont pas je parle
anglais aussi ce qui permet de bien rock
ou plus d'articles sûr pas encore
chinois malheureusement mais j'aimerais
bien ça donnerait encore plus de deux
chinois
c'est aller les impressions de ces flics
mais mais beaucoup à la formation
scientifique c'est quand même un plus
pour aller plus loin c'est en même temps
une espèce de ce maudit comme ça parce
qu'on n'a pas envie de couper à chaque
fois on lit des trucs plus intéressant
on a envie d'aller voir aller plus loin
et du coup bas d'un petit texte qui
devait faire trop de suite mais sinon on
qualités personnelles peut-être que je
suis assez enthousiaste pour faire
croire aux gens que tout peut aller très
vite fait rêver plantes dans l'intérieur
aux questions
surtout les plantes bouillonnec sassou
l'impasse au tir mais j'essaye d'être
d'être enthousiaste et enfin je suis en
tous désormais vidé kong et qu'on me dit
viens on va faire un poker ouais super
je sais pas fermé aux halles et sur
twitter
ça peut être drôle et du coup ça me
donne la motivation d'apprendre beaucoup
de trucs différentes
donc c'est rien très bien mais j'essaye
un peu tout vous ouais et du coup voilà
c'est intéressant d'apprendre de plein
champ à avoir cette vision globale un
peu de plein de support différent d'un
jeu à trois obtenir le côté scientifique
parce que wigan d'autres scientifiques
macky sall est all-in orient qui le
retient
enthousiaste et motivé à faire les
choses se passaient pas faire encore
parce que j'ai deux caïds et oracle est
impressionnant et bien moi je pense que
ça rejoint un peu parce que je pense
qu'on a pas mal de similitudes de domme
parcours mais si je devais en retenir un
truc que je pense que le truc qui pas
trop mal même si ça aussi le revers de
la médaille c'est que je les impôts tant
que ça va tester plein de trucs à faire
du multimédia
c'est à dire que j'ai testé le blog
l'illustration chez des interventions
face public avec différents types de
public j'ai fait des maternelles du
collège du lycée du retraité j'ai eu
chez de la radio je suis intervenu dans
d'autres choses des collaborations aussi
avec des copains par exemple une fois
pour aborder l'éthologie j'ai fait un
partenariat que la gazette du sorcier
qui incite sur harry potter et on s'est
dit c'est une bonne idée de partir pour
quatre ans par altérer pas de la
représentation de la mythologie pour
parler des animaux aussi aujourd'hui ou
de comment les sorciers traite les
centaures pour voir comment les moldus
très petit certaines espèces animales
etc
essayez de plusieurs angles un petit peu
originaux
je suis pas mal de collaboration en fait
pas avec des gens de youtube du coup je
pense que je fasse très confidentielles
sur les internets
les gens me connaissent pas beaucoup
mais j'essaie de faire plein de colle
avec plein de gens pour essayer d'avoir
justement de points de vue différents et
essayer de voir un autre angle de vue
sur la façon d'apporter de localisation
testé plein de choses ça s'est hissé sa
réflexion et monter les collaborations
ces étoiles et à moi qu'est-ce que je
fais mieux que tourner des maths
pourquoi il ya un truc que je pense
faire mieux que tout le monde c'est être
à fond dans l'optimisation du processus
est vraiment optimisé à fond de trucs
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à comment
optimiser le fais et je pense que je
suis pas trop mal utilisé quoi de tout
le système de projection des vidéos de
ce soit l'application d'information
l'argent formation le choix des sujets
l'écriture du script le montage pour
narrer montage mais je pense faire ça
vite et je pense que je suis aussi très
bon pour ne pas être perfection c'est un
truc fait au mieux qu'un truc parfait
dirais-je patty schnyder von stein donc
je passe il ya peu plus la tribune of
experience et transition
entendu parler un petit peu quelques-uns
peut-être qu'on peut parler un peu vite
fait de cette tribune du coup kaka ou
votre sentiment à la fois c'est une
tribune importante dans le sens où
effectivement il ya un problème sur
comment la la communication scientifique
est fait aujourd'hui notamment dans les
grands médias
ou c'est parce que le temps de la
recherche et le temps de la
médiatisation n'est pas la même le dans
les médias on va chercher à avoir une
réponse
cotisez agatha d'une réponse tout de
suite ici et maintenant
alors que le temps d'arracher beaucoup
plus longs ou plus nuancé et du coup les
gens peuvent comme disait la tribune
étaient amants faire leur marché entre
les les les différents contenus
scientifiques pour pouvoir étayer
n'importe quelle position mais du coup
la science perd son statut de d'essayer
de dire comment le monde et devient
juste une source de justification
campement arbitraire donc là tu sais ces
tribus est importante mais d'un autre
côté je trouvais qu'elle n'était pas
très bien rédigé en particulier il ya
une aile il ya il est suggéré plusieurs
fois dans la tribune
il suggérait que la science pourrait
répondre à nos questions même à des
questions peut-être politique par
exemple il ya beaucoup d'exemples sonné
par exemple sur l'énergie nucléaire et
10 l'énergie nucléaire ne produit pas de
co2 ce qui est vrai que ça peut être
utilisé contre le réchauffement
climatique
mais est ce que le pontet dans sa
tribune la n'est pas ça pourrait et ça
devrait le parce que l'énergie nucléaire
même si elle ne produit pas de co2
poserait d'autres questions par ailleurs
qui sont des questions politiques et en
fait le principal reproche que j'aurai à
faire dans cette tribune là ce serait la
confusion entre le descriptif et le
prescriptif entre qu'est-ce-qui rôle en
fait qu'est ce qui relève de la
description du monde ce que fait la
science
et qu'est ce qui relève des décisions
qui doivent être prises dans la société
et c'est à dire qu'ils sont dans le
champ politique et c'est cette confusion
là qui vous fait penser qu'il y ait une
tribune un petit peu positiviste quelque
part dans l'esprit ce qui - le post
croit les ententes sont typiques donc
finalement 6
bonne transition parce que ta citation
au mieux une quelque chose de pas
parfait mais fait pour pouvoir faire
parce que en effet donc moi j'ai signé
cette tribune
on me pose la question est en effet les
pas exemptes de défauts
il ya énormément de choses qui fait que
en effet les questions scientifiques
comme j'ai dis plutôt un sujet
scientifique il arrive pas tenues il est
dans un contexte politique et même on le
voit si on fait un peu de sociologie des
controverses
le problème n'est pas perdu mais d'avoir
vernon de sociologie des sciences et
d'avoir découvert justement ce point de
vue là que pour une production selon
quel groupe ait appartenue on va avoir
des stratégies de cadrage différentes
qui fait que les conclusions à l'absence
ne vont pas être les mêmes à une
association anti nucléaire ne va pas
avoir les mêmes les finalement les mêmes
réflexes que une agence réglementaire
par rapport à la même même fait
scientifique exemple même d'actualité
aujourd'hui
on a découvert des concentrations de
tritium dans l'eau dans l'eau potable de
certaines une de france alors les
associations anti nucléaires pourront
vous dire c'est anormal d'avoir de la
radioactivité plus élevé que
naturellement et une agence
réglementaires vous dira oui mais c'est
pas dans les seuils sanitaires
problématique
donc pour le même résultat selon la
question politique à laquelle se
rattachent
chacune des bords on va avoir des
réactions différentes et donc c'est
peut-être ça qu'un sous-estimer cette
tribune l'impact politique que peuvent
avoir fait certaines suggestions
malgré qu'ils essayaient de ils ont fait
quand même preuve de prudence dans le
pour le nucléaire ils ont rajouté le e
pour justement indiqué que dans un cadre
europe politique et c'est parce que
c'est une nucléaire qu'il faut a priori
lochte des des problématiques
écologiques
on peut avoir un intérêt donc faut pas
exclure cette
cette source par par nature parce que
c'est nucléaire que ça doit pas être
dans l'écologie ça doit être fort les
énergies renouvelables le doivent être
une source d'énergie hors nucléaire ça
c'est un choix vraiment la politique et
les sciences ne peut donner que effet
alors même là parce que je suis en train
de réaliser c'est une pro c'est quelque
chose de très très naïf j'ai pas une
formation suffisamment pointus en
sciences humaines pour avoir exactement
tous les détails mais c'est est ce que
finalement c'était un des reproches de
la tribune qu'il n'y avait pas
suffisamment de représentants de
sciences humaines et parfois sa
pâtisserie peur c'était pas le but
forcément de ceux qui ont rédigé cette
tribune mais ce sont des questions
légitimes puisque là ce qui nous
intéresse c'est un combat politique
c'est à dire ceux qui font les
scientifiques pour lutter contre ces
fameuses de sciences et des prises de
position politiques parfois délirantes
quand on connaît certains faits actuels
mais c'est comme tout la société qu'ils
accusent de très complexe des sciences
essaye d'avoir une vision claire et les
sciences humaines ont tout à fait leur
place dans cette tribune et j'espère les
voir les rejoindre à l'avenir si cette
tribune a évolué la france qu'elle
évolue et il me semble qu'une faq est en
construction donc tu oublies continuer
d' une des figures en revanche personne
ne le semble avoir entendu des
relancé apparemment une faq serait parce
qu'il pense parce que ça déclenche et
énormément de réactions et les errances
a juste dit à l'impression d'avoir été
mal compris ça me semblerait des plus
logique qu'ils essayent de s'éclaircir
et donc j'ai entendu unir peut-être en
off que il essaierait de répondre un
petit peu assez problématique
prochaine communication ça serait
intéressant mais j'ai aussi
techniquement vu qu'il ya 1400
signatures spécifications je crois qu'il
n'y a plus maintenant presque quatre ans
je suis dépassée par l'actualité
s'ajuste pas de famille des pays il ya
plein de polémiques autour de cette
tribune par le seul mérite est là pour
moi c'est juste d'exister pour signifier
qu'il ya un problème
et pour que les gens se rendent compte
que ceux qui écrivent des articles
scientifiques qui des fois
s'autoproclama journalistes
scientifiques n'ont pas souvent et
laissez pas ces critiques le monde a des
compétences différentes et des
journalistes qui sont des compétences de
rédaction etc
des fois il leur manque la compétence de
scientifiques même s'il traite d'un
sujet scientifique donc c'est des gens
qui savent pas forcément lire des études
qui sont pas capables d'évaluer un
consensus scientifique et du coup il ya
besoin d'une complémentarité de discours
et il ya besoin de prendre en compte des
informations qui sont pas très bien
accessible et c'est pour ça que bah
c'est important d'avoir des
vulgarisateurs c'est pour ça que c'est
important de faire le lien avec des
chercheurs qui travaillent sur le sujet
et voilà donc pour moi cette tribune est
très largement un parfait dans sa
formulation et c'est parce que
elle est formulée de façon c'est direct
et très scientiste quelque part voilà la
science et sari du coup il faut oui il
faut penser ça les problèmes sont tous
beaucoup plus complexe que ça et donc ça
serait pas à suffire mais c'est au moins
un premier pas vers attention tout ce
que tout ce que l'on raconte sur
internet c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça vous c'est une seule info ne
suffit pas et peut-être que ça demande
plus de réflexions les plus d'esprit
critique hull et voilà que c'est son
budget principal et elle va être
améliorée c'est déjà un vantard et c'est
mieux que rien
peut-être c'est aussi par lui et
aujourd'hui ce soutien certains
scientifiques
oui bien sûr je les ai tous les jours en
lice et son fils l'aide aux personnes
qui veulent réagir à cette tribune
discussion animée sur les réseaux
sociaux
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
des bons à venir qui vous critiquent me
semble tout à fait valide également
prouvé ce tous dans cette façon de
communiquer des silences façon générale
alors j'ai dernière question sera
délicate également
j'ai allumé la question que vous faites
donc imaginer que vous aviez que vous
avez trois minutes de discussion en tête
à tête avec mac ou qu'est ce que vous
lui direz par exemple autour de lui
raser 60 ific
trois minutes avec quelqu'un d'important
en largeur désabonner c'était ma
participation
je veux dire maquereau ou le président
de la république et le président de la
république mais pas forcément en fait
quelqu'un d'important qui a du pouvoir
et de l' influence
vous aviez premier pour le convaincre de
quelque chose c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui est complètement débile mais qui
n'est pas forcément très au courant de
tout ce qui se passe tout dans le new
jersey scientifique mais
vous avez un peu de temps avec cette
personne est ce qu un sujet en
particulier m comment je pense que je
dirais un truc mais là c'est une
question on y répond à chaud évidemment
qu'ils en avaient cette opportunité on y
réfléchir et donc je vais sûrement très
drôle et un peu débile mais je me lance
il faut bien fixer le jeu de cartes je
pense je dirais si tu veux vraiment
rester dans l'histoire alors oui je les
tue poids mouche wesh wesh tu veux
rester dans l'histoire images des sorts
ou une meuf si plus mon honorable
j'espère jouer résident ici faut pas
déconner égalité des sexes tout ça bref
donc je dirais si tu veux rester dans
l'histoire
l'éducation c'est sur le long terme que
ça fasse voir donc plutôt que d'essayer
de marquer les choses en emparer forme
pense à ce qui va être utile et qu'on
retiendra dans 100 ans de siècle
peut-être
et du coup c'est auprès des enseignants
que ça se passe wesh wesh
merci pour la pompe non non ça c'est
plus enfin indépendamment de la façon
dont on le dit c'est plus avoir une
vision de long terme et du coup
d'essayer de sortir de du résultat
politique et de juste la carrière de
politique et je pense que je lui serai
dans un moment il ya des vertus
thérapeutiques et que je suis beaucoup
pris dans ma chronique
malgré des bons pour vous parler
directement à moi et peut-être une
connerie aussi à chaud on est parti la
tête et bernat salles qui me parlent
directement de khouildi pas le prédire
locaux vont descendre son tabouret pour
nous voir je pense que c'est un message
que j'ai et que pas mal de gens
aimeraient passer au gouvernement c'est
franchement d'un round en battant au
parce que les gens qui sont déjà en haut
ils sont plus aucune notion de la
réalité de ce qui s'est passé en bas et
ils ont beau faire de la com dieu vous
avez compris tout ça et je veux dire
c'est des modes de vie et des strates de
sociétés qui sont tellement de
différence de la majorité des gens que
je que ça me semble inconcevable qu'on
puisse être encore connectés dans les
problématiques de la vie quotidienne aux
gens à de pareilles mois à être mais
c'est dur enfin juste que les
initiatives et la jvm d'en bas et pas de
groupe de personnes dont mais ça c'est
des idées politiques personnelles je ne
suis pas très forte en politique dévoyée
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
démissionne et donne le pouvoir aux gens
et surtout financière cherche justement
monsieur le président nous parlons du
financement il est lyonnais you we
messieurs le président puisque nous
parlons du financement de la recherche
de plus en plus la recherche financée
par projet c'est à dire que on en est on
à un financement sur cinq ans pour
embaucher des post hoc ou des thésards
de plus en plus de gens qui travaillent
de façon précaire est de moins en moins
de fonds pour créer des des postes
permanents et du coup à les gens qui
sont à des postes permanents passe de
plus en plus de temps à chercher les
financements pour recruter ces précaires
et les précaires n'ont aucune garantie
d'avoir un poste plus tard donc le le
nombre de gens dans la recherche
précaire augmenter le nombre de postes
diminue ce qui fait que de moins en
moins de gens qui se lancent dans leurs
recherches pourront finir par avoir ces
pose donc
serait-il possible monsieur le président
de revenir un financement permanent de
façon à ce que les gens les jeunes qui
se lancent dans la recherche puisse ne
pas s'inquiéter pour leur avenir puisse
travailler sur des projets de façon plus
permanente au lieu de chercher la
publication à tout prix et l'instantané
et que et que en sécurisant ainsi la le
financement de la recherche
on est moins d'incitations à corrompre
nos propres résultats ou à se copient
les uns les autres
c'est une idée intéressante donc
monsieur le président pourquoi essayer
de peut faire de redondance avec camara
dont s'est développé
j'aimerais que d'une part dans la
culture soit aussi à bord mise en place
aussi que dans la culture il ya aussi la
culture scientifique et une culture
comme des autres donc c'est à dire qu'il
ya des institutions qui ont la culture
scientifique et qui ont besoin de moyens
vont continuer à exister un bon je pense
forcément aux balles et les découvertes
qui est malheureusement en train d'être
un petit peu sur une mauvaise pente est
certainement ce n'est pas forcément des
plus roses du fait notamment parce que
il ya des manques de moyens et que la
culture scientifique est pas mise par le
même piédestal que la culture et donc
n'a pas accès aux mêmes financements et
aux mêmes moyens que c'est ce
valorisation de la culture même sa
touche
tu parlais de la recherche ça touche
aussi des recherches il n'y a je me
souviens plus
cette base documentaire est aussi de la
culture scientifique de la conserver les
anciens matériels et ancien de données
qui sont autant de matériaux précieux
pour les générations futures pour
pouvoir continuer à prendre la science
le travail des historiens qui se base
sur ces données sur ces archives et que
des conservateurs n'ont plus forcément
les moyens de maintenir en place parce
que c'est la culture scientifique et
c'est pas aussi le joli que rate un
boulot qu'on peut exposer dans un musée
ou une oeuvre musicale peut on peut
chanter dans un terrain donc la culture
scientifique c'est aussi une culture
c'est un tout 30 endroit la préservation
aller et à la valorisation que n'importe
quel autre tueur créé par l'être humain
super monsieur le président de vous
rencontrer
attendez à faire quelques blagues mais
maintenant que vous êtes là de préciser
la fonction présidentielle impressionne
trop je n'abandonne attend de gaudriole
non je me garderai bien ouais donc en
tant que président je pense que vous
avez un plan je connais pas les détails
un certain pouvoir
le service public c'est l'ensemble de
fonctionnaires si j'ai bien compris et
donc si vous pouviez avoir une
quelconque influence sur le service
public notamment france télévisions on
vous arrangé pour que des émissions de
grande écoute là soient encadrés par je
sais pas des références scientifiques ou
autres pour s'assurer que des messages
qui se formant des messages dollars en
première partie de soirée soient
délivrés soit de qualité ne fasse pas
croire des gens des choses un peu
bizarre et sinon c'est dommage que je
vous rends compte maintenant parce qu'il
ya trois semaines j'avais dans ma
costumes et je vais vous demander
l'adresse de votre tailleur
mais trop tard j'ai trouvé une voie très
bien j'étais trop petit pour ce sera
tout
[Musique]
je suis pas contente
trois appartements poney pour une
société qu'elle fonctionne bien il faut
de l'éducation pour tous
donc faudrait d'études pour la culture
que la culture aille même chez ceux qui
n'y ont pas accès facilement aux données
d'études dans des tuyaux chercheurs dont
qu'ils arrêtent de fouiller les bas
fonds pour en trouver
et puis d essayer aussi de revenir aux
faits quoi il ya plein de décisions que
vous avez prises qui sont pas basées sur
des faits scientifiques prouver je vais
pas vous parler de la chasse mais un
voile à abattre des renards des
blaireaux pour établir la biodiversité
ça n'a jamais fonctionné demande à ma
pense qu'elle peut loger le site il vous
le dira donc ça serait cool d'écouter
plus scientifiques et l'organisation
disent les scientifiques comme si les
gens auxquels vous demander des rapports
et en fait après vous les lisez pas
voilà c'est ces gens là en fait à
l'équipe allez y les crimes des rapports
comme ça donc voilà on consulte des gens
des spécialistes et tous et écrire des
rapports mais après bas n'est décision
visiblement ça suis pas trop donc il va
falloir faire un petit effort quand même
commencé à lire les rapports
je pense que ça peut être important puis
après bien évidemment comme tout le
monde a dit donner un peu d'argent sur
le long terme parce que bon cinq ans
c'est pas vraiment donc un petit peu
plus d'effort là dessus or je pense et
puis tu vois ce sera un bon début et ses
nobles
et là on a beaucoup parlé
finalement qu'on donne pas quand même
l'impression de parler que des sciences
inhumaines dur qu'eux aussi aussi les
organismes réglementaires pouvait avoir
les moyens de protéger d'avoir justement
le pouvoir faire ces rapports et que
certaines académies soit un peu plus
scientifique
c'est pas que je pense que l'académie
française people et la moïse qui verrait
que il ya des choses à réviser et que tu
fais pas forcément du bien pour les
objectifs que tu prétends défendre donc
la linguistique les sciences humaines
aussi leur part a donné donc pour
établir une politique elles ont toutes
eu droit au chapitre que les sciences
techniques et plus dur qui semble à
portée du profit économique les sciences
politiques et sociales aussi elles ont
des choses pouvoir apporter
même s'il semble moins facile de faire
du fric directement avec mais elles sont
tout aussi intéressants pour pouvoir
quelque chose au long terme qui marche
parce que ce système qui marche c'est la
science qui marche c'est l'éducation qui
marche c'est tout qui marche donc
écouter scientifique super si quelqu'un
devait arrêter quelque chose mais je
pense qu'on est un peu trop consensuelle
autour de sable qui je suis pas d'accord
christian faut pas trop trop écouter les
scientifiques donc lui dans le sens où
on est des humains comme les autres puis
là où je trouve entendre un peu dans
leur piège mais qui est dû au format du
podcast on devrait prendre un show où en
fait on donne notre opinion sur un truc
mais bon je pense moi en tout cas je
sais pas pour les autres qui en parlent
et on a clairement mais moi j'ai
clairement pas la culture qui permet pas
je pense pas pouvoir donner une opinion
vraiment pertinente comme ça en cinq
minutes
je pense justement que c'est
collectivement et peu juste les
scientifiques on va se poser face est
une vraie question de démocratie et de
quelles sont les valeurs qu'on veut
mettre en avant et comment ils y arriver
ça prend du temps de
voir des bonnes réponses et oui une
approche scientifique peut aider à avoir
ces répondants cui il faut des
scientifiques mais pas que il faut un
petit peu tout le monde du coup je me
sens trahi il a par cette question nous
oblige à répondre des trucs
en fait on tombe dans ce piège dont on
veut répondre immédiatement un truc
qu'on a sur le coeur n'est probablement
pas le meilleur truc à faire oui et puis
ça pourrait aussi donner l'impression
qu'on est tous des bisounours et qu'on a
eu aucune conscience des réalités
matérielles de lâcher sur leur pays et
des finances
et c'est à dire que s'il ya du budget
par l'argent vous à votre part donc il
faut un système économique etc
c'est des questions super complexe
l'idée c'est juste que peut-être là
c'est le moment de réfléchir à des
écosystèmes de société qu'ils sont plus
intelligents et plus durable sur le long
terme et là ça va pas se faire dans go
avec juste un petit groupe de gens qui
décident pour le reste mais ça sert avec
l'intelligence collective des genres
dont l'utilité de consulter tous les
gens à disposition dans les cités au
plaignant un maximum de dégoter s'est
déroulé ce que tu dire directement au
président de la régie parce que
peut-être lui peut mettre en place des
choses dans ce sens ou parce que voilà
des idées comme le référendum
d'initiative populaire
ça ne semblait idéale hormis des
problèmes de participation parce que des
gens ils doivent d'abord être informés
que on veut leur avis et que vous leur
avez à donner et je pense que toutes les
tranches de la société alors riche elle
pourrait donner leur avis d'une certaine
manière et être consultées d'une façon
pertinente pareil ça demande du temps de
la réflexion de l'investissement mais je
pense que sam exploitant toutes les
forces qu'on a qu'on va arriver à
quelque chose et pas juste en demandant
une personne pour n'est allé dans une
usure d'un jour pour pourrir que sa
tâche et voilà on attend peut-être trop
que les gens viennent d'en haut
magiquement d'une personne alors que bah
ils devraient acheter avec démocratie
directe en fait je le simple format de
la question en fait fait que on répond à
la fois en tant que scientifique et en
tant que militant et je suis assez
d'accord avec clean sur le fait que
la science les experts les scientifiques
vont pouvoir effectivement dire pour un
objectif donné quel va être le moyen d'y
arriver quelles vont être les
conséquences d'y arriver mais c'est pas
pour autant que les scientifiques
devraient être ceux qui décident ce
qu'ils décident ça devrait que les
premiers concernés
on peut discuter sur quelle est la
meilleure forme de gouvernement mais le
il ya d'une part la prise de décision
politique qui est du champ du champ
politique et mais la science est là en
fait pour servir et si jamais on pour
éclairer elle doit être là et c'est bien
qu'on soit consultée sur des questions
pour dire ce qu'il en est mais si jamais
c'était les scientifiques qui devenaient
les dirigeants on se mettrait à faire
plus de la politique que de la science
on on essaierait d'infléchir le résultat
pour servir nos intérêts personnels ou
non nous intérêts de classe ou de castes
on est serré et c'est donc je pense que
c'est très bien c'est henri point la
question mais je pense que c'est très
bien quand même de garder à l'esprit que
même si les scientifiques doivent être
consultés le pouvoir politique doit être
séparé du pouvoir scientifique
j'écoute les scientifiques mais pas trop
si c'est à vous de écouter les
scientifiques pour savoir ce qu'est le
monde mais que pour ce qui est de
décider quel futur on veut ça c'est une
question qu'on ne débatte tous ensemble
qu'est ce que je devais faire pour
organiser un débat sur ça il ya des apps
il ya des propositions qui ont été
faites par exemple évidemment on voit on
va pas gouverner tout un pays sous le
régime de l'assemblée générale mais il y
avait l'idée que par exemple en une
décision on peut tirer au hasard un
certain nombre de personnes dont qui
vont être représentatif de l'ensemble de
la population de leur donner une série
d'interventions par des experts afin
qu'ils soient plus éduqués sur le sujet
et qu'ils puissent du coup prendre
conscience du consensus scientifique ce
qui est important c'est que ces experts
soit contradictoire c'est-à-dire que les
gens aient accès à différentes tendances
qui lie à dans le sujet traité
elle passe à un seul point de vue et
dans un deuxième volet léger de
s'assurer sur plusieurs semaines donc
les gens peuvent mature et ça et après
les gens peuvent
gentile ressort peuvent ensuite demander
à voir des gens auxquels on n'aurait pas
pensé donc les gens reprennent
l'initiative selon les experts qui
veulent consulter et ensuite seulement
les gens construisent la proposition de
loi la constitution là le texte final
qui ainsi ce sera à la fois
représentatif de la vie de la population
et à la fois tenant compte des réalités
de scientifiques actuelles de conclure
c'est bon on peut donc je pense que
cette question est intéressante en fait
j'ai croisé beaucoup plus et cela
poserait de personnes alors cette vodka
est haletant et c'est vraiment là
prendre sérieusement de vie voire le
second l'a entre nous tous des blagues
et tout ça à chaud surtout moins chaud
une question qui est en face au tout cas
merci beaucoup
le café des sciences d'avoir participé à
ce probablement et merci aux idées et
aux hordes mtv et je vous dis à bientôt
probablement